recorded books presents
an unabridged recording of
the war of art
winning the inner creative battle
by stephen pressfield
narrated by george waddell
this book is copyrighted 2002 by stephen
pressfield
this recording is copyrighted 2003 by
recorded books
this book opens with the following
forward by robert mckee
stephen pressfield wrote the war of art
for me
he undoubtedly wrote it for you too
but i know he did it expressly for me
because i hold olympic records for
procrastination
i can procrastinate thinking about my
procrastination problem i can
procrastinate dealing with my problem of
procrastinating thinking about my
procrastination problem
so pressfield that devil asked me to
write this forward against a deadline
knowing that no matter how much i
stalled eventually i'd have to knuckle
down and do the work
at the last possible hour i did and as i
lift through book one defining the enemy
i saw myself staring back guilty-eyed
from every page
but then book two gave me a battle plan
book three a vision of victory
and as i closed the war of art i felt a
surge of positive calm
i now know i can win this war
and if i can
so can you
to begin book one pressfield labels the
enemy of creativity resistance
his all-encompassing term for what freud
called the death wish
that destructive force inside human
nature that rises whenever we consider a
tough long-term course of action that
might do for us or others something
that's actually good
he then presents a rogues gallery of the
many manifestations of resistance
you will recognize each and every one
for this force lives within us all
self-sabotage
self-deception
self-corruption
we writers know it as block a paralysis
whose symptoms can bring on appalling
behavior
some years ago i was as blocked as a
calcutta sewer so what did i do
i decided to try on all my clothes
to show just how anal i can get i put on
every shirt pair of pants sweater jacket
and sock sorting them into piles spring
summer fall winter salvation army
then i tried them on all over again
this time parsing them into spring
casual spring formal summer casual
two days of this and i thought i was
going mad
want to know how to cure writer's block
it's not a trip to your psychiatrist for
as pressfield wisely points out seeking
support is resistance at its most
seductive
no
the cure is found in book two
turning pro
steven pressfield is the very definition
of a pro
i know this because i can't count the
times i called the author of the legend
of bagger vance to invite him for a
round of golf and although tempted he
declined
why
because he was working
and as any writer who has ever taken a
backswing nose golf is a beautifully
vigilant form of procrastination
in other words
resistance
steve packs a discipline forged of
bethlehem steel
i read steve's gates of fire and tides
of war back to back while traveling in
europe
now i'm not a lacrimos guy i hadn't
cried over a book since the red pony but
these novels got to me
i found myself sitting in cafes choking
back tears over the selfless courage of
those greeks who shaped and saved
western civilization
as i looked beneath his seamless prose
and sensed his depth of research of
knowledge of human nature and society of
vividly imagined telling details
i was in awe of the work the work all
the work that built the foundation of
his riveting creations
and i'm not alone in this appreciation
when i bought the books in london i was
told that steve's novels are now
assigned by oxford history dons who tell
their students that if they wish to rub
shoulders with life in classical greece
read pressfield
how does an artist achieve that power
in the second book pressfield lays out
the day-by-day step-by-step campaign of
the professional
preparation
order
patience endurance
acting in the face of fear and failure
no excuses
no [ __ ]
and best of all
steve's brilliant insight that first
last and always the professional focuses
on mastery of the craft
book three the higher realm
looks at inspiration that sublime result
that blossoms in the furrows of the
professional who straps on the harness
and plows the fields of his or her art
in pressfield's words when we sit down
each day and do our work
power concentrates around us
we become like a magnetized rod that
attracts iron filings
ideas come
insights accrete on this the effect of
inspiration steve and i absolutely agree
indeed stunning images and ideas arrive
as if from nowhere in fact these
seemingly spontaneous flashes are so
amazing it's hard to believe that our
unworthy selves created them
from where therefore does our best stuff
come
it's on this point however the cause of
inspiration that we see things
differently
in book one steve traces resistance down
its evolutionary roots to the genes
i agree the cause is genetic
that negative force that dark antagonism
to creativity is embedded deep in our
humanity
but in book three he shifts gears and
looks for the cause of inspiration not
in human nature but on a higher realm
then with a poetic fire he lays out his
belief in muses and angels
the ultimate source of creativity he
argues is divine
many perhaps most readers will find book
three profoundly moving
i on the other hand believe that the
source of creativity is found on the
same plane of reality as resistance
it too is genetic
it's called talent
the innate power to discover the hidden
connection between two things images
ideas
words
that no one else has ever seen before
link them and create for the world a
third utterly unique work
like our iq
talent is a gift from our ancestors
if we're lucky we inherit it
in the fortunate talented few
the dark dimension of their natures will
first resist the labor that creativity
demands but once they commit to the task
their talented side stirs to action and
rewards them with astonishing feats
these flashes of creative genius seem to
arrive from out of the blue for the
obvious reason
they come from the unconscious mind
in short if the muse exists
she does not whisper to the untalented
so although steve and i may differ on
the cause we agree on the effect
when inspiration touches talent she
gives birth to truth and beauty
and when stephen pressfield was riding
the war of art
she had her hands all over him
and now
the war of art
what i do
i get up take a shower have breakfast
i read the paper brush my teeth
if i have phone calls to make i make
them i've got my coffee now i put on my
lucky work boots and stitch up the lucky
laces that my niece meredith gave me
i head back to my office crank up the
computer
my lucky hooded sweatshirt is draped
over the chair with the lucky charm i
got from a gypsy in santa maria de la
mer for only eight bucks and franks and
my lucky largo name tag that came from a
dream i once had
i put it on
on my thesaurus is my lucky cannon that
my friend bob versandi gave me from
morrow castle cuba
i point it toward my chair so it can
fire inspiration into me
i say my prayer which is the invocation
of the muse from homer's odyssey
translation by t.e lawrence lawrence of
arabia which my dear mate paul rink gave
me and which sits near my shelf with the
cufflinks that belonged to my father and
my lucky acorn from the battlefield at
thermopylae
it's about 10 30 now
i sit down
and plunge in
when i start making typos i know i'm
getting tired
that's four hours or so
i've hit the point of diminishing
returns
i wrap for the day copy whatever i've
done to disc and stash the disc in the
glove compartment of my truck in case
there's a fire and i have to run for it
i power down
it's three three thirty the office is
closed how many pitches have i produced
i don't care
are they any good i don't even think
about it
all that matters is i've put in my time
and hit it with all i've got
all that counts is that for this day for
this session
i have overcome
resistance
what i know
there's a secret that real writers know
that wannabe writers don't
and the secret is this
it's not the writing part that's hard
what's hard is sitting down to write
what keeps us from sitting down
is resistance
the unlived life
most of us have two lives
the life we live
and the unlived life within us
between the two
stands resistance
have you ever brought home a treadmill
and let it gather dust in the attic ever
quit a diet a course of yoga a
meditation practice have you ever bailed
out on a call to embark upon a spiritual
practice dedicate yourself to a
humanitarian calling commit your life to
the service of others have you ever
wanted to be a mother a doctor an
advocate for the weak and helpless to
run for office crusade for the planet
campaign for world peace or to preserve
the environment
late at night
have you experienced a vision of the
person you might become
the work you could accomplish
they realized being you were meant to be
are you a writer who doesn't write
a painter who doesn't paint
an entrepreneur who never starts a
venture
then you know
what resistance is
one night i was laying down i heard papa
talking to mama i heard papa say to let
that boy boogie woogie cause it's in him
and it's got to come out
john lee hooker
boogie chillin
resistance
is the most toxic force on the planet
it is the root of more unhappiness than
poverty disease and erectile dysfunction
to yield to resistance deforms our
spirit
it stunts us and makes us less than we
are and we're born to be
if you believe in god and i do
you must declare resistance evil
for it prevents us from achieving the
life god intended when he endowed each
of us with our own unique genius
genius is a latin word the romans used
it to denote an inner spirit holy and
inviolable which watches over us guiding
us to our calling
a writer writes with his genius
an artist paints with hers
everyone who creates
operates from this sacramental center
it is our soul's seat
the vessel that holds our being in
potential
our stars beacon and polaris
every sun casts a shadow and geniuses
shadow is resistance
as powerful as is our soul's call to
realization
so potent are the forces of resistance
arrayed against it
resistance is faster than a speeding
bullet more powerful than a locomotive
harder to kick than crack cocaine
we're not alone if we've been mowed down
by resistance millions of good men and
women have bitten the dust before us
and here's the biggest [ __ ] we don't
even know what hit us i never did
from age 24 to 32
resistance kicked my ass from east coast
to west and back again 13 times and i
never even knew it existed
i looked everywhere for the enemy and
failed to see it right in front of my
face
have you heard this story
woman learns she has cancer six months
to live within days she quits her job
resumes the dream of writing tex-mex
songs she gave up to raise a family or
starts studying classical greek or moves
to the inner city and devotes herself to
tending babies with aids
women's friends think she's crazy she
herself has never been happier there's a
postscript woman's cancer goes into
remission
is that what it takes
do we have to stare death in the face to
make us stand up and confront resistance
does resistance have to [ __ ] and
disfigure our lives before we wake up to
its existence
how many of us have become drunks and
drug addicts developed tumors and
neuroses succumbed to painkillers gossip
and compulsive cell phone use simply
because we don't do that thing that our
hearts our inner genius is calling us to
resistance defeats us
if tomorrow morning by some stroke of
magic every dazed and benighted soul
woke up with the power to take the first
step toward pursuing his or her dreams
every shrink in the directory would be
out of business
prisons would stand empty
the alcohol and tobacco industries would
collapse along with the junk food
cosmetic surgery and infotainment
businesses not to mention pharmaceutical
companies hospitals and the medical
profession from top to bottom
domestic abuse would become extinct as
would addiction obesity migraine
headaches road rage and dandruff
look in your own heart unless i'm crazy
right now a still small voice is piping
up telling you as it has ten thousand
times the calling that is yours and
yours alone you know it no one has to
tell you
and unless i'm crazy you're no closer to
taking action on it than you were
yesterday or will be tomorrow
you think resistance isn't real
resistance will bury
you you know hitler wanted to be an
artist
at 18 he took his inheritance 700 cronin
and moved to vienna to live and study he
applied to the academy of fine arts and
later to the school of architecture
ever see one of his paintings
neither have i
resistance beat him
call it overstatement
but i'll say it anyway
it was easier for hitler to start world
war ii
than it was for him to face a blank
square of canvas
book one
resistance
defining the enemy
the enemy is a very good teacher
the dalai lama
resistance's greatest hits
the following is a list in no particular
order of those activities that most
commonly elicit resistance
one
the pursuit of any calling in writing
painting music film dance or any
creative art however marginal or
unconventional
two
the launching of any entrepreneurial
venture or enterprise for profit or
otherwise
three any diet or health regimen
four
any program of spiritual advancement
five any activity whose aim is tighter
abdominals
six any course or program designed to
overcome an unwholesome habit or
addiction
seven
education of every kind
eight
any act of political moral or ethical
courage including the decision to change
for the better some unworthy pattern of
thought or conduct in ourselves
nine
the undertaking of any enterprise or
endeavor whose aim is to help others
ten any act that entails commitment of
the heart
the decision to get married to have a
child to weather a rocky patch in a
relationship
eleven
the taking of any principled stand in
the face of adversity
in other words any act that rejects
immediate gratification in favor of
long-term growth health or integrity or
expressed another way any act that
derives from our higher nature instead
of our lower
any of these will elicit resistance
now
what are the characteristics of
resistance
resistance is invisible
resistance cannot be seen touched heard
or smelled
but it can be felt
we experience it as an energy field
radiating from a working potential it's
a repelling force it's negative
its aim is to shove us away
distract us
prevent us from doing our work
resistance is internal
resistance seems to come from outside
ourselves we located in spouses jobs
bosses kids
peripheral opponents as pat riley used
to say when he coached the los angeles
lakers
resistance is not a peripheral opponent
resistance arises from within
it is self-generated and
self-perpetuated
resistance is the enemy within
resistance is insidious
resistance will tell you anything to
keep you from doing your work
it will perjure fabricate falsify seduce
bully
cajole
resistance is protein it will assume any
form if that's what it takes to deceive
you
it will reason with you like a lawyer or
jam a nine millimeter in your face like
a stick up man
resistance has no conscience it will
pledge anything to get a deal then
double-cross you as soon as your back is
turned
if you take resistance at its word
you deserve everything you get
resistance is always lying
and always full of [ __ ]
resistance is implacable
resistance is like the alien or the
terminator or the shark and jaws it
cannot be reasoned with
it understands nothing but power it is
an engine of destruction programmed from
the factory with one object only to
prevent us from doing our work
resistance is implacable intractable
indefatigable
reduce it to a single cell and that cell
will continue to attack
this is resistance is nature
it's all it knows
resistance is impersonal
resistance is not out to get you
personally it doesn't know who you are
and doesn't care
resistance is a force of nature it acts
objectively
though it feels malevolent resistance in
fact operates with the indifference of
rain
and transits the heavens by the same
laws as the stars
when we marshal our forces to combat
resistance
we must remember this
resistance is infallible
like a magnetized needle floating on a
surface of oil
resistance will unfailingly point to
true north
meaning that calling or action it most
wants to stop us from doing
we can use this we can use it as a
compass
we can navigate by resistance
letting it guide us to that calling or
action that we must follow before all
others
rule of thumb the more important a call
or action is to our soul's evolution
the more resistance we will feel toward
pursuing it
resistance is universal
we're wrong if we think we're the only
ones struggling with resistance
everyone who has a body
experiences resistance
resistance never sleeps
henry fonda was still throwing up before
each stage performance even when he was
75.
in other words fear doesn't go away
the warrior and the artist live by the
same code of necessity which dictates
that the battle must be fought anew
every day
resistance plays for keeps
resistance's goal is not to wound or
disable
resistance aims to kill
its target is the epicenter of our being
our genius our soul
the unique and priceless gift we were
put on earth to give and that no one
else has but us
resistance means business
when we fight it
we're in a war to the death
resistance is fueled by fear
resistance has no strength of its own
every ounce of juice it possesses comes
from us
we feed it with power by our fear of it
master that fear
and we conquer resistance
resistance only opposes in one direction
resistance obstructs movement only from
a lower sphere to a higher
it kicks in when we seek to pursue a
calling in the arts launch an innovative
enterprise or evolve to a higher station
morally ethically or spiritually so
if you're in calcutta working with the
mother teresa foundation and you're
thinking of bolting to launch a career
in telemarketing relax
resistance will give you a free pass
resistance is most powerful
at the finish line
odysseus almost got home years before
his actual homecoming ithaca was in
sight
close enough that the sailors could see
the smoke of their family's fires on
shore
odysseus was so certain he was safe he
actually laid down for a snooze it was
then
that his men believing there was gold in
an oxhide sack among their commander's
possessions snatched this prize and cut
it open
the bag contained the adverse winds
which king eolis had bottled up for
odysseus when the wanderer had touched
earlier at his blessed isle
the winds burst forth now in one mad
blow driving odysseus's ships back
across every league of ocean they had
with such difficulty traversed making
him endure further trials and sufferings
before
at last and alone he reached home for
good
the danger is greatest
when the finish line is in sight
at this point resistance knows we're
about to beat it
it hits the panic button it marshals one
last assault and slams us with
everything it's got
the professional must be alert for this
counter-attack
wary at the end don't open that bag of
wind
resistance recruits allies
resistance by definition is
self-sabotage but there's a parallel
peril that must also be guarded against
sabotaged by others
when a writer begins to overcome her
resistance in other words when she
actually starts to write
she may find that those close to her
begin acting strange
they may become moody or sullen they may
get sick they may accuse the awakening
writer of changing of not being the
person she was
the closer these people are to the
awakening writer the more bizarrely they
will act and the more emotion they will
put behind their actions
they are trying to sabotage her
the reason is that they are struggling
consciously or unconsciously against
their own resistance
the awakening writer's success becomes a
reproach to them if she can beat these
demons why can't they
often couples or close friends even
entire families will enter into tacit
compacts whereby each individual pledges
unconsciously to remain mired in the
same slew in which she and all her
cronies have become so comfortable
the highest treason a crab can commit
is to make a leap for the rim of the
bucket
the awakening artist must be ruthless
not only with herself but with others
once you make your break
you can't turn around for your buddy who
catches his trouser leg on a barbed wire
the best thing you can do for that
friend and he'd tell you this himself if
he really is your friend
is to get over the wall and keep
motivating
the best and only thing that one artist
can do for another is to serve as an
example and an inspiration
now
let's consider the next aspect of
resistance
symptoms
resistance and procrastination
procrastination is the most common
manifestation of resistance because it's
the easiest to rationalize
we don't tell ourselves i'm never going
to write my symphony instead we say i'm
going to write my symphony i'm just
going to start tomorrow
resistance and procrastination part 2.
the most pernicious aspect of
procrastination is that it can become a
habit
we don't just put off our lives today
we put them off till our deathbed
never forget this very moment we can
change our lives
there never was a moment and never will
be when we are without the power to
alter our destiny this second we can
turn the tables on resistance
this second we can sit down and do our
work
resistance
and sex
sometimes resistance takes the form of
sex or an obsessive preoccupation with
sex
why sex because sex provides immediate
and powerful gratification
when someone sleeps with us
we feel validated and approved of even
loved
resistance gets a big kick out of that
it knows it has distracted us with a
cheap easy fix and kept us from doing
our work
of course not all sex is a manifestation
of resistance in my experience you can
tell by the measure of hollowness you
feel afterward the more empty you feel
the more certain you can be that your
true motivation was not love
or even lust
but resistance
it goes without saying that this
principle applies to drugs shopping
masturbation tv gossip alcohol
and the consumption of all products
containing fat sugar salt or chocolate
resistance
and
trouble we get ourselves in trouble
because it's a cheap way to get
attention
trouble is a faux form of fame
it's easier to get busted in the bedroom
with the faculty chairman's wife than it
is to finish that dissertation on the
metaphysics of motley in the novellas of
joseph conrad
ill health is a form of trouble as are
alcoholism and drug addiction proneness
to accidents all neurosis including
compulsive screwing up and such
seemingly benign foibles as jealousy
chronic lateness and the blasting of rap
music at 110 db from your smoked glass
95 supra
anything that draws attention to
ourselves through pain-free or
artificial means
is a manifestation of resistance
cruelty to others is a form of
resistance as is the willing endurance
of cruelty from others
the working artist will not tolerate
trouble in her life because she knows
trouble prevents her from doing her work
the working artist banishes from her
world all sources of trouble
she harnesses the urge for trouble and
transforms it in her work
resistance and self-dramatization
creating soap opera in our lives is a
symptom of resistance
why put in years of work designing a new
software interface
when you can get just as much attention
by bringing home a boyfriend with a
prison record
sometimes entire families participate
unconsciously in a culture of
self-dramatization
the kids fuel the tanks the grown-ups
arm the phasers the whole starship
lurches from one spine tingling episode
to another
and the crew knows how to keep it going
if the level of drama drops below a
certain threshold
someone jumps in to amp it up
dad gets drunk mom gets sick janie shows
up for church with an oakland raiders
tattoo
it's more fun than a movie and it works
nobody gets a damn thing done
sometimes i think of resistance as a
sort of evil twin to santa claus
who makes his rounds house to house
making sure that everything's taken care
of
when he comes to a house that's hooked
on self-dramatization his ruddy cheeks
glow and he giddy-ups away behind his
eight tiny reindeer he knows there'll be
no work done in that house
resistance and self-medication
do you regularly ingest any substance
controlled or otherwise whose aim is the
alleviation of depression anxiety etc
i offer the following experience i once
worked as a writer for a big new york ad
agency
our boss used to tell us invent a
disease come up with the disease he said
and we can sell the cure
attention deficit disorder seasonal
affect disorder social anxiety disorder
these aren't diseases they're marketing
ploys doctors didn't discover them
copywriters did
marketing departments did drug companies
did
depression and anxiety may be real
but they can also be resistance
when we drug ourselves to blot out our
soul's call we are being good americans
and exemplary consumers
we're doing exactly what tv commercials
and pop materialist culture have been
brainwashing us to do from birth
instead of applying self-knowledge
self-discipline delayed gratification
and hard work
we simply consume a product
many pedestrians have been maimed or
killed at the intersection of resistance
and commerce
resistance and victimhood
doctors estimate that 70 to 80 percent
of their business
is non-health related
people aren't sick they're
self-dramatizing
sometimes the hardest part of a medical
job is keeping a straight face
as jerry seinfeld observed of his 20
years of dating
that's a lot of acting fascinated
the acquisition of a condition lends
significance to one's existence
an illness
a cross to bear
some people go from condition to
condition they cure one and another pops
up to take its place
the condition becomes a work of art in
itself a shadow version of the real
creative act the victim is avoiding by
expending so much care cultivating his
condition
a victim act is a form of passive
aggression
it seeks to achieve gratification not by
honest work or a contribution made out
of one's experience or insight or love
but by the manipulation of others
through silent and not so silent threat
the victim compels others to come to his
rescue or to behave as he wishes by
holding them hostage to the prospect of
his own further illness meltdown mental
dissolution or simply by threatening to
make their lives so miserable that they
do what he wants
casting yourself as a victim
is the antithesis of doing your work
don't do it
if you're doing it stop
resistance and the choice of a mate
sometimes if we're not conscious of our
own resistance we'll pick as a mate
someone who has or is successfully
overcoming resistance
i'm not sure why
maybe it's easier to endow our partner
with the power that we in fact possess
but are afraid to act upon
maybe it's less threatening to believe
that our beloved spouse is worthy to
live out his or her unlived life while
we are not
or maybe we're hoping to use our mate as
a model
maybe we believe or wish we could that
some of our spouses power will rub off
on us if we just hang around it long
enough
this is how resistance disfigures love
stew it creates is rich it's colorful
tennessee williams could work it up into
a trilogy but is it love
if we're the supporting partner
shouldn't we face our own failure to
pursue our unlived life rather than
hitchhike on our spouse's coattails
and if we're the supported partner
shouldn't we step out from the glow of
our loved one's adoration and instead
encourage him to let his own light shine
resistance
and this book
when i began this book
resistance almost beat me
this is the form it took it told me the
voice in my head that i was a writer of
fiction not non-fiction
and that i shouldn't be exposing these
concepts of resistance literally and
overtly rather i should incorporate them
metaphorically into a novel
that's a pretty damn subtle and
convincing argument the rationalization
resistance presented me with was that i
should write say a war piece in which
the principles of resistance were
expressed as the fear a warrior feels
resistance also told me i shouldn't seek
to instruct or put myself forward as a
purveyor of wisdom that this was vain
egotistical possibly even corrupt and
that it would work harm to me in the end
that scared me
it made a lot of sense
what finally convinced me to go ahead
was simply that i was so unhappy not
going ahead
i was developing symptoms
as soon as i sat down and began
i was okay
resistance
and unhappiness
what does resistance feel like
first
unhappiness we feel like hell
a low-grade misery pervades everything
we're bored we're restless we can't get
no satisfaction
there's guilt but we can't put our
finger on the source
we want to go back to bed we want to get
up and party we feel unloved and
unlovable we're disgusted we hate our
lives we hate ourselves
unalleviated resistance mounts to a
pitch that becomes unendurable at this
point vices kick in dope adultery web
surfing
beyond that resistance becomes clinical
depression aggression dysfunction
then actual crime and physical
self-destruction
sounds like life i know it isn't
it's resistance
what makes it tricky is that we live in
a consumer culture that's acutely aware
of this unhappiness and has masked all
its profit-seeking artillery to exploit
it by selling us a product a drug
a distraction
john lennon once wrote
well you think you're so clever and
classless and free
but you're all [ __ ] peasants
as far as i can see
as artists and professionals it is our
obligation to enact our own internal
revolution a private insurrection inside
our own skulls
in this uprising we free ourselves from
the tyranny of consumer culture
we overthrow the programming of
advertising movies video games magazines
tv and mtv by which we have been
hypnotized from the cradle
we unplug ourselves from the grid by
recognizing that we will never cure our
restlessness by contributing our
disposable income to the bottom line of
[ __ ] incorporated but only by doing
our work
resistance and fundamentalism
the artist and the fundamentalist
both confront the same issue
the mystery of their existence as
individuals
each asks the same questions who am i
why am i here what is the meaning of my
at
life
primitive stages of evolution humanity
didn't have to deal with such questions
in the states of savagery of barbarism
in nomadic culture medieval society in
the tribe and the clan one's position
was fixed by the commandments of the
community
it was only with the advent of modernity
starting with the ancient greeks with
the birth of freedom and of the
individual that such matters ascended to
the fore
these are not easy questions who am i
why am i here they're not easy because
the human being isn't wired to function
as an individual we're wired tribally
to act as part of a group
our psyches are programmed by millions
of years of hunter-gatherer evolution
we know what the clan is we know how to
fit into the band and the tribe
what we don't know is how to be alone
we don't know how to be free individuals
the artist and the fundamentalist arise
from societies at differing stages of
development
the artist is the advanced model his
culture possesses affluence stability
enough excessive resource to permit the
luxury of self-examination
the artist is grounded in freedom
he is not afraid of it he is lucky he
was born in the right place
he has a core of self-confidence of hope
for the future he believes in progress
and evolution his faith is that
humankind is advancing however haltingly
and imperfectly toward a better world
the fundamentalist entertains no such
notion
in his view
humanity has fallen from a higher state
the truth is not out there awaiting
revelation it has already been revealed
the word of god has been spoken and
recorded by his prophet behe jesus
muhammad or karl marx
fundamentalism is the philosophy of the
powerless the conquered the displaced
and the dispossessed
its spawning ground is the wreckage of
political and military defeat
as hebrew fundamentalism arose during
the babylonian captivity as white
christian fundamentalism appeared in the
american south during reconstruction
as the notion of the master race evolved
in germany following world war one
in such desperate times the vanquished
race would perish without a doctrine
that restored hope and pride
islamic fundamentalism ascends from the
same landscape of despair and possesses
the same tremendous and potent appeal
what exactly is this despair
it is the despair
of freedom
the dislocation and emasculation
experienced by the individual cut free
from the familiar and comforting
structures of the tribe and the clan the
village and the family
it is the state of modern life
the fundamentalist or more accurately
the beleaguered individual who comes to
embrace fundamentalism
cannot stand freedom
he cannot find his way into the future
so he retreats to the past
he returns in imagination to the glory
days of his race and seeks to
reconstitute both them and himself in
their purer more virtuous light
he gets back to basics to fundamentals
fundamentalism and art
are mutually exclusive there is no such
thing as fundamentalist art
this does not mean that the
fundamentalist is not creative rather
his creativity is inverted he creates
destruction
even the structures he builds his
schools and networks of organization
are dedicated to annihilation of his
enemies and of himself
but the fundamentalist reserves his
greatest creativity
for the fashioning of satan
the image of his foe in opposition to
which he defines and gives meaning to
his own life
like the artist the fundamentalist
experiences
resistance
he experiences it as temptation to sin
resistance to the fundamentalist is the
call of the evil one seeking to seduce
him from his virtue
the fundamentalist is consumed with
satan whom he loves as he loves death
is it coincidence that the suicide
bombers of the world trade center
frequented strip clubs during their
training or that they conceived of their
reward as a squadron of virgin brides
and the license to ravish them in the
flesh parts of heaven
the fundamentalist hates and fears women
because he sees them as vessels of satan
temptresses like delilah who seduced
samson from his power
to combat the call of sin that is
resistance the fundamentalist plunges
either into action or into the study of
sacred texts
he loses himself in these much as the
artist does in the process of creation
the difference is that while the one
looks forward hoping to create a better
world the other looks backward seeking
to return to a pure world from which he
and all have fallen
the humanist believes that humankind as
individuals is called upon to co-create
the world with god
this is why he values human life so
highly in his view things do progress
life does evolve each individual has
value at least potentially in advancing
this cause
the fundamentalist cannot conceive of
this
in his society dissent is not just crime
but apostasy it is heresy
transgression against god himself
when fundamentalism wins
the world enters a dark age
yet still i can't condemn one who is
drawn to this philosophy
i consider my own inner journey the
advantages i've had of education
affluence family support health and the
blind good luck to be born american
and still i have learned to exist as an
autonomous individual if indeed i have
only by a whisker and at a cost i would
hate to have to reckon up
it may be that the human race is not
ready for freedom
the air of liberty may be too rarefied
for us to breathe
certainly i wouldn't be writing this
book on this subject if living with
freedom were easy
the paradox seems to be as socrates
demonstrated long ago
that the truly free individual
is free only to the extent of his own
self-mastery
while those who will not govern
themselves
are condemned to find masters
to govern over them
resistance and criticism
if you find yourself criticizing other
people
you're probably doing it out of
resistance
when we see others beginning to live
their authentic selves
it drives us crazy if we have not lived
out our own
individuals who are realized in their
own lives almost never criticize others
if they speak at all it is to offer
encouragement
watch yourself of all the manifestations
of resistance most only harm ourselves
criticism and cruelty harm others as
well
resistance and self-doubt
self-doubt can be an ally
this is because it serves as an
indicator of aspiration
it reflects love
love of something we dream of doing and
desire desire to do it
if you find yourself asking yourself and
your friends am i really a writer am i
really an artist
chances are you are the counterfeit
innovator
is wildly self-confident
the real one
is scared to death
resistance and fear
are you paralyzed with fear
that's a good sign
fear is good
like self-doubt fear is an indicator
fear tells us what we have to do
remember our rule of thumb the more
scared we are of a work or calling
the more sure we can be that we have to
do it
resistance is experienced as fear the
degree of fear equates to the strength
of resistance therefore the more fear we
feel about a specific enterprise
the more certain we can be that that
enterprise is important to us and to the
growth of our soul
that's why we feel so much resistance
if it meant nothing to us
there'd be no resistance
have you ever watched inside the actor's
studio
the host james lipton invariably asks
his guests what factors make you decide
to take a particular role
the actor always answers because i'm
afraid of it
the professional tackles the project
that will make him stretch he takes on
the assignment that will bear him into
uncharted waters compel him to explore
unconscious parts of himself
is he scared hell yes he's petrified
conversely the professional turns down
roles that he's done before he's not
afraid of them anymore why waste his
time
so if you're paralyzed with fear it's a
good sign
it shows you what you have to do
resistance and love
resistance is directly proportional to
love if you're feeling massive
resistance
the good news is
it means there's tremendous love there
too
if you didn't love the project that is
terrifying you
you wouldn't feel anything
the opposite of love isn't hate it's
indifference
the more resistance you experience the
more important your unmanifested art
project enterprise
is to you and the more gratification you
will feel when you finally do it
resistance
and being a star
grandiose fantasies are a symptom of
resistance they're the sign of an
amateur
the professional has learned that
success like happiness comes as a
byproduct of work
the professional concentrates on the
work and allows rewards to come or not
come whatever they like
resistance and isolation
sometimes we balk at embarking on an
enterprise because we're afraid of being
alone
we feel comfortable with the tribe
around us it makes us nervous going off
into the woods on our own
here's the trick
we're never alone
as soon as we step outside the campfire
glow
our muse lights on our shoulder like a
butterfly
the act of courage calls forth
infallibly that deeper part of ourselves
that supports and sustains us
have you seen interviews with the young
john lennon or bob dylan when the
reporter tries to ask about their
personal selves
the boys deflect these queries with
withering sarcasm why
because lenin and dylan know that the
part of them that writes the songs is
not them
not the personal self that is of such
surpassing fascination to their
bone-headed interrogators
lennon and dylan also know that the part
of themselves that does the writing is
too sacred too precious
too fragile to be redacted into sound
bites for the titillation of would-be
idolaters who are themselves caught up
in their own resistance
so they put them on and blow them off
it is a commonplace among artists and
children at play
that they're not aware of time or
solitude while they're chasing their
vision the hours fly
the sculptures and the tree climbing
tyke both look up blinking when mom
calls supper time
resistance and isolation part two
friends sometimes ask don't you get
lonely sitting by yourself all day
at first it seemed odd to hear myself
answer no
then i realized that i was not alone
i was in the book
i was with the characters i was with my
self
not only do i not feel alone with my
characters they are more vivid and
interesting to me than the people in my
real life
if you think about it the case can't be
otherwise in order for a book or any
project or enterprise to hold our
attention for the length of time it
takes to unfold itself
it has to plug into some internal
perplexity or passion that is of
paramount importance to us
that problem becomes the theme of our
work even if we can't at the start
understand or articulate it
as the characters arise each embodies
infallibly an aspect of that dilemma
that perplexity
these characters might not be
interesting to anyone else
but they're absolutely fascinating to us
they are us
meaner smarter sexier versions of
ourselves it's fun to be with them
because they're wrestling with the same
issue that has its hooks into us they're
our soul mates our lovers our best
friends even the villains
especially the villains
even in a book like this which has no
characters
i don't feel alone because i'm imagining
the reader whom i conjure as an aspiring
artist much like my own younger less
grizzled self to whom i hope to impart a
little starch and inspiration and prime
a little with some hard knocks wisdom
and a few tricks of the trade
resistance and healing
have you ever spent time in santa fe
there's a subculture of healing there
the idea is that there's something
therapeutic in the atmosphere a safe
place to go and get yourself together
there are other places santa barbara and
ojai california come to mind usually
populated by upper middle class people
with more time and money than they know
what to do with in which a culture of
healing also obtains
the concept in all these environments
seem to be that one needs to complete
his healing before he is ready to do his
work
this way of thinking are you ahead of me
is a form of resistance
what are we trying to heal anyway the
athlete knows the day will never come
when he wakes up pain-free he has to
play hurt
remember the part of us that we imagine
needs healing
is not the part we create from
that part is far deeper and stronger the
part we create from can't be touched by
anything our parents did or society did
that part is unsullied uncorrupted
soundproof waterproof and bulletproof
in fact the more troubles we've got the
better and richer that part becomes
the part that needs healing
is our personal life
personal life has nothing to do with
work besides what better way of healing
than to find our center of
self-sovereignty
isn't that the whole point of healing
i washed up in new york a couple of
decades ago making 20 bucks a night
driving a cab and running away full-time
from doing my work
one night alone in my 110 dollar a month
sublet i hit bottom in terms of having
diverted myself into so many phony
channels so many times that i couldn't
rationalize it for one more evening
i dragged out my ancient smith corona
dreading the experience as pointless
fruitless meaningless not to say the
most painful exercise i could think of
for two hours i made myself sit there
torturing out some trash that i chucked
immediately into the [ __ ] can
that was enough i put the machine away
i went back to the kitchen
in the sink sat 10 days of dishes
for some reason i had enough excess
energy that i decided to wash them
the warm water felt pretty good the soap
and sponge were doing their thing
a pile of clean plates began rising in
the drying rack
to my amazement
i realized i was whistling
it hit me that i had turned a corner
i was okay
i would be okay from here on
do you understand
i hadn't written anything good
it might be years before i would if i
ever did it all that didn't matter what
counted was that i had after years of
running from it actually sat down and
done my work
don't get me wrong i've got nothing
against true healing we all need it
but it has nothing to do with doing our
work and it can be a colossal exercise
in resistance
resistance loves healing
resistance knows that the more psychic
energy we expend dredging and
re-dredging the tired boring injustices
of our personal lives
the less juice we have to do our work
resistance and support
have you ever been to a workshop
these boondoggles are colleges of
resistance
they ought to give out phds in
resistance what better way of avoiding
work than going to a workshop
but what i hate even worse
is the word
support seeking support from friends and
family is like having your people gather
around at your deathbed
it's nice
but when the ship sails all they can do
is stand on the dock waving goodbye
any support we get from persons of flesh
and blood is like monopoly money it's
not legal tender in that sphere where we
have to do our work
in fact the more energy we spend stoking
up on support from colleagues and loved
ones the weaker we become and the less
capable of handling our business
my friend carol had the following dream
at a time when her life felt like it was
careening out of control
she was a passenger on a bus
bruce springsteen was driving suddenly
springsteen pulled over handed carol the
keys and bolted
in the dream carol was panicking how
could she drive this huge rolling
greyhound by now all the passengers were
staring clearly no one else was going to
step forward and take charge
carol took the wheel
to her amazement she found she could
handle it
later analyzing the dream she figured
bruce springsteen was the boss the boss
of her psyche
the bus was the vehicle of her life
the boss was telling carol it was time
to take the wheel
more than that the dream by actually
setting her down in the driver's seat
and letting her feel that she could
control the vehicle on the road was
providing her with a simulator run to
prime her with the confidence that she
could actually take command in her life
a dream like that is real support
it's a check you can cash when you sit
down alone to do your work
ps when your deeper self delivers a
dream like that don't talk about it
don't dilute its power the dream is for
you it's between you and your muse shut
up and use it
the only exception is you may share it
with another comrade in arms if sharing
it will help or encourage that comrade
in his or her own endeavors
resistance and rationalization
rationalization is resistance's
right-hand man
its job is to keep us from feeling the
shame we would feel
if we truly faced what cowards we are
for not doing our work
michael
don't knock rationalization
where would we be without it i don't
know anyone who can get through the day
without two or three juicy
rationalizations they're more important
than sex
sam ah come on
nothing's more important than sex
michael oh yeah
have you ever gone a week without a
rationalization
jeff goldblum and tom barringer in
lawrence kasdan's the big chill
but rationalization has its own sidekick
it's that part of our psyche that
actually believes what rationalization
tells us
it's one thing to lie to ourselves
it's another thing to believe it
resistance and rationalization
part two
resistance
is fear but resistance is too cunning to
show itself naked in this form why
because if resistance lets us see
clearly that our own fear is preventing
us from doing our work
we may feel shame at this and shame may
drive us to act in the face of fear
resistance doesn't want us to do this so
it brings in
rationalization rationalization is
resistance's spin doctor
it's resistance's way of hiding the big
stick behind its back
instead of showing us our fear which
might shame us and impel us to do our
work resistance presents us with a
series of plausible rational
justifications for why we shouldn't do
our work
what's particularly insidious about the
rationalizations that resistance
presents to us is that a lot of them are
true
they're legitimate
our wife may really be in her eighth
month of pregnancy she may in truth need
us at home
our department may really be instituting
a changeover that will eat up hours of
our time indeed it may make sense to put
off finishing our dissertation at least
till after the baby's born
what resistance leaves out of course
is that all this means diddly
tolstoy had 13 kids and wrote war and
peace
lance armstrong had cancer and won the
tour de france three years and counting
resistance can be beaten
if resistance couldn't be beaten there
would be no fifth symphony no romeo and
juliet no golden gate bridge
defeating resistance is like giving
birth it seems absolutely impossible
until you remember that women have been
pulling it off successfully with support
and without
for 50 million years
book two
combating resistance
turning
pro
it is one thing to study war
and another
to live the warrior's life
telemon of arcadia mercenary of the 5th
century bc
professionals and amateurs
aspiring artists defeated by resistance
share one trait they all think like
amateurs
they have not yet turned pro the moment
an artist turns pro is as epical as the
birth of his first child
with one stroke everything changes
i can state absolutely that the term of
my life can be divided into two parts
before turning pro and after
to be clear when i say professional i
don't mean doctors and lawyers those of
the professions i mean the professional
as an ideal
the professional in contrast to the
amateur
consider the differences
the amateur plays for fun
the professional plays for keeps
to the amateur the game is his avocation
to the pro it's his vocation
the amateur plays part-time the
professional full-time the amateur is a
weekend warrior the professional is
there seven days a week
the word amateur comes from the latin
root meaning to love
the conventional interpretation is that
the amateur pursues his calling out of
love while the pro does it for money not
the way i see it
in my view the amateur does not love the
game enough if he did he would not
pursue it as a sideline distinct from
his real vocation
the professional loves it so much he
dedicates his life to it he commits full
time
that's what i mean when i say turning
pro
resistance hates it
when we turn pro
a professional
someone once asked somerset mom
if he wrote on a schedule or only when
struck by inspiration
i write only when inspiration strikes he
replied fortunately it strikes every
morning at nine o'clock sharp
that's a pro
in terms of resistance more more saying
i despise resistance i will not let it
faze me i will sit down and do my work
morm reckoned another deeper truth that
by performing the mundane physical act
of sitting down and starting to work
he set in motion a mysterious but
infallible sequence of events that would
produce inspiration as surely as if the
goddess had synchronized her watch with
his
he knew if he built it she would come
what a writer's day feels like
i wake up with a gnawing sensation of
dissatisfaction
already i feel fear
already the loved ones around me are
starting to fade i interact i'm present
but i'm not
i'm not thinking about the work
i've already consigned that to the muse
what i am aware of is resistance i feel
it in my guts
i afford it the utmost respect because i
know it can defeat me on any given day
as easily as the need for a drink can
overcome an alcoholic
i go through the chores the
correspondence the obligations of daily
life again i'm there but not really the
clock is running in my head i know i can
indulge in daily crap for a little while
but i must cut it off when the bell
rings
i'm keenly aware of the principle of
priority which states a you must know
the difference between what is urgent
and what is important
and b
you must do what's important first
what's important is the work
that's the game i have to suit up for
that's the field on which i have to
leave everything i've got
do i really believe that my work is
crucial to the planet's survival of
course not
but it's as important to me as catching
that mouse is to the hawk circling
outside my window he's hungry he needs a
kill
so do i
i'm done with my chores now it's time
i say my prayer
and head out on the hunt
the sun isn't up yet it's cold the
fields are sopping brambles scratch my
ankles branches snap back in my face the
hill is a son of a [ __ ] but what can
you do
set one foot in front of another and
keep climbing
an hour passes
i'm warmer now
the pace has got my blood going the
years have taught me one skill how to be
miserable
i know how to shut up and keep humping
this is a great asset because it's human
the proper role for a mortal
it does not offend the gods but elicits
their intercession
my bitching self is receding now the
instincts are taking over another hour
passes
i turn the corner of a thicket
and there he is the nice fat hair i knew
would show up if i just kept plugging
home from the hill i thank the immortals
and offer up their portion of the kill
they brought it to me they deserve their
share i am grateful
i joke with my kids beside the fire
they're happy the old man has brought
home the bacon the old lady's happy
she's cooking it up
i'm happy i've earned my keep on the
planet at least for this day
resistance is not a factor now i don't
think of the hunt and i don't think of
the office the tension drains from my
neck and back what i feel and say and do
this night will not be coming from any
disowned or unresolved part of me any
part corrupted by resistance
i go to sleep content
but my final thought is of resistance i
will wake up with it tomorrow
already i'm stealing myself
how to be miserable
in my younger days dodging the draft
i somehow wound up in the marine corps
there's a myth that marine training
turns baby-faced recruits into
bloodthirsty killers trust me the marine
corps is not that efficient
what it does teach however is a lot more
useful
the marine corps teaches you how to be
miserable
this is invaluable for an artist
marines love to be miserable marines
derive a perverse satisfaction in having
colder chow crappier equipment and
higher casualty rates than any outfit of
dog faces swab jockeys or fly boys all
of whom they despise
why
because these candy asses don't know how
to be miserable
the artist committing himself to his
calling has volunteered for hell whether
he knows it or not
he will be dining for the duration on a
diet of isolation rejection self-doubt
despair ridicule contempt and
humiliation
the artist must be like that marine he
has to know how to be miserable he has
to love being miserable he has to take
pride in being more miserable than any
soldier or swabby or jet jockey because
this is war baby and war is hell
we're all pros already
all of us are pros in one area our jobs
we get a paycheck
we work for money we are professionals
now
are there principles we can take from
what we're already successfully doing in
our work day life and apply to our
artistic aspirations
what exactly are the qualities that
define us as professionals
one
we show up every day
we might do it only because we have to
to keep from getting fired but we do it
we show up every day
two
we show up no matter what in sickness
and in health come hell or high water we
stagger into the factory we might do it
only so as not to let down our
co-workers or for other less noble
reasons but we do it
we show up no matter what
we stay on the job all day
our minds may wander but our bodies
remain at the wheel
we pick up the phone when it rings we
assist the customer when he seeks our
help
we don't go home till the whistle blows
four
we are committed over the long haul
next year we may go to another job
another company another country but will
still be working
until we hit the lottery we are part of
the labor force
five
the stakes for us are high and real
this is about survival feeding our
families educating our children it's
about eating
six
we accept remuneration for our labor
we're not here for fun we work for money
seven
we do not over identify with our jobs
we may take pride in our work we may
stay late and come in on weekends but we
recognize that we are not our job
descriptions the amateur on the other
hand over identifies with his avocation
his artistic aspiration he defines
himself by it
he is a musician a painter a playwright
resistance loves this resistance knows
that the amateur composer will never
write his symphony because he is overly
invested in its success and over
terrified of its failure
the amateur takes it so seriously it
paralyzes him
eight
we mastered the technique of our jobs
nine
we have a sense of humor about our jobs
ten
we receive praise or blame in the real
world
now consider the amateur the aspiring
painter the wannabe playwright
how does he pursue his calling one
he doesn't show up every day
two
he doesn't show up no matter what three
he doesn't stay on the job all day
he is not committed over the long haul
the stakes for him are illusory and fake
he does not get money and he over
identifies with his art he does not have
a sense of humor about failure you don't
hear him bitching this [ __ ] trilogy
is killing me instead
he doesn't write his trilogy at all
the amateur has not mastered the
technique of his art nor does he expose
himself to judgment in the real world
if we show our poem to our friend and
our friend says it's wonderful i love it
that's not real world feedback that's
our friend being nice to us
nothing is as empowering as real world
validation even if it's for failure
the first professional writing job i
ever had after 17 years of trying
was on a movie called king kong lives
i and my partner at the time ron shusset
a brilliant writer and producer who also
did alien and total recall hammered out
the screenplay for dino de laurentiis
we loved it we were sure we had a hit
even after we'd seen the finished film
we were certain it was a blockbuster
we invited everyone we knew to the
premier even rented out the joint next
door for a post-triumph blowout
get there early we warned our friends
the place will be mobbed
nobody showed
there was only one guy in line beside
our guests
and he was muttering something about
spare change
in the theater our friends endured the
movie in mute stupefaction
when the lights came up
they fled like cockroaches into the
night
next day came the review and variety
ronald schussett and stephen pressfield
we hope these are not their real names
for their parents sake
when the first week's grosses came in
the flick barely registered
still i clung to hope maybe it's only
tanking in urban areas maybe it's
playing better in the burbs
i motored to an edge city multiplex a
youth man the popcorn booth how's king
kong lives i asked he flashed thumbs
down miss it man it sucks
i was crushed
here i was 42 years old divorced
childless having given up all normal
human pursuits to chase the dream of
being a writer now i've finally got my
name on a big time hollywood production
starring linda hamilton and what happens
i'm a loser a phony my life is worthless
and so am i
my friend tony keplerman snapped me out
of it by asking if i was going to quit
hell no
then be happy you're where you wanted to
be aren't you so you're taking a few
blows that's the price for being in the
arena and not on the sidelines stop
complaining and be grateful
that was when i realized i'd become a
pro
i had not yet had a success
but i had had a real failure
for love of the game
to clarify a point about professionalism
the professional though he accepts money
does his work out of love he has to love
it
otherwise he wouldn't devote his life to
it of his own free will
the professional has learned however
that too much love can be a bad thing
too much love can make him choke
the seeming detachment of the
professional the cold-blooded character
to his demeanor is a compensating device
to keep him from loving the game so much
that he freezes in action
playing for money
or adopting the attitude of one who
plays for money
lowers the fever
remember what we said about fear love
and resistance
the more you love your art calling
enterprise the more important its
accomplishment is to the evolution of
your soul
the more you will fear it and the more
resistance you will experience facing it
the payoff of playing the game for money
is not the money which you may never see
anyway even after you turn pro
the payoff is that playing the game for
money produces the proper professional
attitude it inculcates the lunch pail
mentality the hard core hard head hard
hat state of mind that shows up for work
despite rain or snow or dark of night
and slugs it out day after day
the writer is an infantryman
he knows that progress is measured in
yards of dirt extracted from the enemy
one day one hour one minute at a time
and paid for in blood
the artist wears combat boots
he looks in the mirror and sees gi joe
remember the muse favors working stiffs
she hates prima donnas
to the gods the supreme sin is not rape
or murder but pride
to think of yourself as a mercenary a
gun for hire implants the proper
humility it purges pride and
preciousness
resistance loves pride and preciousness
resistance says show me a writer who's
too good to take job x or assignment y
and i'll show you a guy i can crack like
a walnut
technically
the professional takes money
technically the pro plays for pay
but in the end he does it for love
now let's consider
what are the aspects of the professional
a professional is patient
resistance outwits the amateur with the
oldest trick in the book
it uses his own enthusiasm against him
resistance gets us to plunge into a
project with an over-ambitious and
unrealistic timetable for its completion
it knows we can't sustain that level of
intensity we will hit the wall we will
crash
the professional on the other hand
understands delayed gratification he is
the ant not the grasshopper the tortoise
not the hare
have you heard the legend of sylvester
stallone staying up three nights
straight to churn out the screenplay for
rocky
i don't know it may even be true but
it's the most pernicious species of myth
to set before the awakening writer
because it seduces him into believing he
can pull off the big score without pain
and without persistence
the professional arms himself with
patience not only to give the stars time
to align in his career but to keep
himself from flaming out in each
individual work
he knows that any job whether it's a
novel or a kitchen remodel takes twice
as long as he thinks and costs twice as
much
he accepts that
he recognizes it as reality
the professional steals himself at the
start of a project reminding himself it
is the iditarod not the 60 yard dash
he conserves his energy he prepares his
mind for the long haul
he sustains himself with the knowledge
that if he can just keep those huskies
mushing
sooner or later the sled will pull into
gnome
a professional seeks order
when i lived in the back of my chevy van
i had to dig my typewriter out from
beneath layers of tired tools dirty
laundry and mouldering paperbacks
my truck was a nest a hive a hell hole
on wheels whose sleeping surface i had
to clear each night just to carve out a
foxhole to snooze in
the professional cannot live like that
he is on a mission he will not tolerate
disorder
he eliminates chaos from his world in
order to banish it from his mind
he wants the carpet vacuumed and the
threshold swept so the muse may enter
and not soil or gown
a professional demystifies
a pro views her work as craft not art
not because she believes art is devoid
of a mystical dimension on the contrary
she understands that all creative
endeavor is holy but she doesn't dwell
on it she knows if she thinks about that
too much it will paralyze her
so she concentrates on technique
the professional masters how and leaves
what and why to the gods
like somerset mom she doesn't wait for
inspiration she acts in the anticipation
of its apparition
the professional is acutely aware of the
intangibles that go into inspiration out
of respect for them she lets them work
she grants them their sphere while she
concentrates on hers
the sign of the amateur is over
glorification of and preoccupation with
the mystery
the professional shuts up
she doesn't talk about it
she does her work
a professional acts in the face of fear
the amateur believes he must first
overcome his fear then he can do his
work
the professional knows
that fear can never be overcome
he knows there is no such thing as a
fearless warrior or a dread-free artist
what henry fonda does after puking into
the toilet in his dressing room is to
clean up and march out on stage
he's still terrified but he forces
himself forward in spite of his terror
he knows that once he gets out into the
action
his fear will recede and he'll be okay
a professional accepts no excuses
the amateur underestimating resistance
is cunning permits the flu to keep him
from his chapters
he believes the serpent's voice in his
head that says mailing off that
manuscript is more important than doing
the day's work
the professional has learned better he
respects resistance he knows if he caves
in today no matter how plausible the
pretext he'll be twice as likely to cave
in tomorrow
the professional knows that resistance
is like a telemarketer if you so much as
say hello you're finished
the pro doesn't even pick up the phone
he stays at work
a professional plays it as it lays
my friend the hawk and i were playing
the first hole at prestwick in scotland
the wind was howling out of the left i
started an eight iron thirty yards to
windward but the gale caught it i
watched in dismay as the ball sailed
hard right hit the green going sideways
and bounded off into the cabbage son of
a [ __ ] i turned to our caddy did you
see the wind take that shot
he gave that look that only scottish
caddies can give well you've got to play
the win now don't you
the professional conducts his business
in the real world adversity injustice
bad hops and rotten calls even good
breaks and lucky bounces all comprise
the ground over which the campaign must
be waged the field is level the
professional understands only in heaven
a professional is prepared
i'm not talking about craft that goes
without saying
the professional is prepared at a deeper
level he is prepared each day
to confront his own self-sabotage
the professional understands that
resistance is fertile and ingenious
it will throw stuff at him that he's
never seen before
the professional prepares mentally to
absorb blows and to deliver them his aim
is to take what the day gives him he is
prepared to be prudent and prepared to
be reckless to take a beating when he
has to and to go for the throat when he
can
he understands that the field alters
every day his goal is not victory
success will come by itself when it
wants to but to handle himself
his insides as sturdily and steadily as
he can
a professional does not show off
a professional's work has style
it is distinctively his own but he
doesn't let his signature grandstand for
him his style serves the material he
does not impose it as a means of drawing
attention to himself
this doesn't mean that the professional
doesn't throw down a 360 tomahawk jam
from time to time just to let the boys
know he's still in business
a professional dedicates himself to
mastering technique
the professional respects his craft
he does not consider himself superior to
it he recognizes the contributions of
those who have gone before him he
apprentices himself to them
the professional dedicates himself to
mastering technique not because he
believes technique is a substitute for
inspiration
but because he wants to be in possession
of the full arsenal of skills when
inspiration does come
the professional is sly he knows that by
toiling beside the front door of
technique
he leaves room for genius
to enter by the back
a professional does not hesitate to ask
for help
tiger woods is the greatest golfer in
the world yet he has a teacher he works
with butch harmon
and tiger doesn't endure this
instruction or suffer through it he
revels in it it's his keenest
professional joy to get out there on the
practice tea with butch to learn more
about the game he loves
tiger woods is the consummate
professional
it would never occur to him as it would
to an amateur that he knows everything
or can figure everything out on his own
on the contrary he seeks out the most
knowledgeable teacher and listens with
both ears
the student of the game knows that the
levels of revelation that can unfold in
golf as in any art
are inexhaustible
a professional distances herself from
her instrument
the pro stands at one remove from her
instrument meaning her person her body
her voice her talent the physical mental
emotional and psychological being she
uses in her work she does not identify
with this instrument it is simply what
god gave her what she has to work with
she assesses it coolly impersonally
objectively
the professional identifies with her
consciousness and her will
not with the matter that her
consciousness and will manipulate to
serve her art
does madonna walk around the house in
cone bras and come [ __ ] me bustiers
she's too busy planning d-day
madonna does not identify with madonna
madonna employs madonna
a professional does not take failure or
success
personally
when people say an artist has a thick
skin
what they mean is not that the person is
dense or numb
but that he has seated his professional
consciousness in a place other than his
personal ego
it takes tremendous strength of
character to do this because our deepest
instincts run counter to it
evolution has programmed us to feel
rejection in our guts this is how the
tribe enforced obedience by wielding the
threat of expulsion
fear of rejection isn't just
psychological it's biological it's in
our cells
resistance knows this and uses it
against us
it uses fear of rejection to paralyze us
and prevent us if not from doing our
work than from exposing it to public
evaluation
i had a dear friend who had labored for
years on an excellent and deeply
personal novel it was done he had it in
its mailing box
but he couldn't make himself send it off
fear of rejection unmanned him
the professional cannot take rejection
personally because to do so reinforces
resistance
editors are not the enemy critics are
not the enemy
resistance is the enemy
the battle is inside our own heads we
cannot let external criticism even if
it's true fortify our internal foe
that foe is strong enough already
a professional schools herself to stand
apart from her performance even as she
gives herself to it heart and soul
the bhagavad-gita tells us we have a
right only to our labor not to the
fruits of our labor
all the warrior can give is his life
all the athlete can do is leave
everything on the field
the professional loves her work she is
invested in it wholeheartedly
but she does not forget that the work is
not her her artistic self contains many
works and many performances
already the next is percolating inside
her the next will be better and the one
after that better
still the professional
self-validates
she is tough-minded in the face of
indifference or adulation she assesses
her stuff coldly and objectively
where it fell short she'll improve it
were it triumphed she'll make it better
still
she'll work harder she'll be back
tomorrow
the professional gives an ear to
criticism seeking to learn and grow but
she never forgets that resistance is
using criticism against her on a far
more diabolical level
resistance enlists criticism to
reinforce the fifth column of fear
already at work inside the artist's head
seeking to break her will and crack her
dedication
the professional does not fall for this
her resolution before all others remains
no matter what
i will never let resistance beat me
a professional endures adversity
i had been in tinseltown five years
had finished nine screenplays on spec
none of which it sold
finally got a meeting with the big
producer
he kept taking phone calls even as i
pitched my stuff
he had one of those headset things so he
didn't even have to pick up a receiver
the calls came in and he took them
finally one came that was personal would
you mind he asked indicating the door i
need some privacy on this one
i exited the door closed behind me
ten minutes passed
i was standing out by the secretaries
twenty more minutes passed finally the
producer's door opened he came out
pulling on his jacket
oh i'm so sorry
he had forgotten all about me
i'm human this hurt i wasn't a kid
either i was in my forties with a rap
sheet of failure as long as your arm
the professional cannot let himself take
humiliation personally humiliation like
rejection and criticism is the external
reflection of internal resistance
the professional endures adversity he
lets the bird [ __ ] splash down on his
slicker remembering that it comes clean
with a heavy-duty hosing
he himself his creative center cannot be
buried even beneath a mountain of guano
his core is bulletproof
nothing can touch it unless he lets it
i saw a fat happy old guy once in his
cadillac on the freeway
he had the ac going pointer sisters on
the cd puffing on a stogie his license
plate
dues paid
the professional keeps his eye on the
donut and not on the whole he reminds
himself it's better to be in the arena
getting stomped by the bull than to be
up in the stands or out in the parking
lot
a professional self validates
an amateur lets the negative opinion of
others unman him
he takes external criticism to heart
allowing it to trump his own belief in
himself and his work resistance loves
this
can you stand another tiger wood story
with four holes to go on the final day
of the 2001 masters which tiger went on
to win completing the all four mages at
one time slam
some chucklehead in the gallery snapped
a camera shutter at the top of tiger's
backswing
incredibly tiger was able to pull up in
mid-swing and back off the shot
but that wasn't the amazing part after
looking daggers at the male factor tiger
recomposed himself stepped back to the
ball
and striped it 310 down the middle
that's a professional
it is tough-mindedness at a level most
of us can't comprehend let alone emulate
but let's look more closely at what
tiger did or rather what he didn't do
first he didn't react reflexively he
didn't allow an act that by all rights
should have provoked an automatic
response of rage to actually produce
that rage he controlled his reaction he
governed his emotion
second he didn't take it personally
he could have perceived this
shutterbug's act as a deliberate blow
aimed at him individually with the
intention of throwing him off his shot
he could have reacted with outrage or
indignation or cast himself as a victim
he didn't
third
he didn't take it as a sign of heaven's
malevolence
he could have experienced this bolt as
the malice of the golfing gods like a
bad hop in baseball or a linesman's miss
calling tennis
he could have groaned or sulked or
surrendered mentally to this injustice
this interference and used it as an
excuse to fail
he didn't
what he did do
was maintain his sovereignty over the
moment
he understood that no matter what blow
had befallen him from an outside agency
he himself still had his job to do
the shot he needed to hit right here
right now
and he knew that it remained within his
power to produce that shot
nothing stood in his way except whatever
emotional upset he himself chose to hold
on to
tiger's mother coltida is a buddhist
perhaps from her he had learned
compassion to let go of fury at the
heedlessness of an overzealous shutter
clicker
in any event tiger woods the ultimate
professional
vented his anger quickly with a look
then recomposed himself
and returned to the task at hand
the professional cannot allow the
actions of others to define his reality
tomorrow morning the critic will be gone
but the writer will still be there
facing the blank page
nothing matters but that he keep working
short of a family crisis or the outbreak
of world war three
the professional shows up ready to serve
the gods
remember resistance wants us to cede
sovereignty to others it wants us to
stake our self-worth our identity our
reason for being on the response of
others to our work
resistance knows we can't take this no
one can
the professional blows critics off
he doesn't even hear them
critics he reminds himself are the
unwitting mouthpieces of resistance and
as such can be truly cunning and
pernicious
they can articulate in their reviews the
same toxic venom that resistance itself
concocts inside our heads
that is their real evil not that we
believe them but that we believe the
resistance in our own minds
for which critics serve as unconscious
spokespersons
the professional learns to recognize
envy driven criticism and to take it to
what it is the supreme compliment
the critic hates most
that which he would have done himself if
he had had the guts
a professional recognizes her
limitations
she gets an agent she gets a lawyer she
gets an accountant she knows she can
only be a professional at one thing
she brings in other pros
and treats them with respect
a professional reinvents himself
goldie hawn once observed that there are
only three ages for an actress in
hollywood
babe d.a and driving miss daisy
she was making a different point but the
truth remains
as artists we serve the muse
and the muse may have more than one job
for us over our lifetime
the professional does not permit himself
to become hide bound within one
incarnation
however comfortable or successful
like a transmigrating soul he shucks his
outworn body and dons a new one he
continues his journey
a professional is recognized by other
professionals
the professional senses who has served
his time and who hasn't
like alan led and jack palance circling
each other in chain
a gun recognizes another gun
you
incorporated
when i first moved to los angeles and
made the acquaintance of working
screenwriters
i learned that many had their own
corporations
they provided their writing services not
as themselves but as loan outs from
their one-man businesses
their writing contracts were fso for
services of themselves
i'd never seen this before i thought it
was pretty cool
for a writer to incorporate himself has
certain tax and financial advantages but
what i love about it is the metaphor
i like the idea of being myself
incorporated
that way i can wear two hats i can hire
myself and fire myself
i can even as robin williams once
remarked of writer producers blow smoke
up my own ass
making yourself a corporation or just
thinking of yourself in that way
reinforces the idea of professionalism
because it separates the artist doing
the work from the will and consciousness
running the show
no matter how much abuse is heaped on
the head of the former the latter takes
it in stride and keeps on trucking
conversely with success
you the writer may get a swelled head
but you the boss remember how to take
yourself down a pig
have you ever worked in an office
then you know about monday morning
status meetings
the group assembles in the conference
room and the boss goes over what
assignments each team member is
responsible for in the coming week
when the meeting breaks up an assistant
prepares a worksheet and distributes it
when this hits your desk an hour later
you know exactly what you have to do
that week
i have one of those meetings with myself
every monday i sit down and go over my
assignments then i type it up and
distribute it to myself
i have corporate stationery and
corporate business cards and a corporate
checkbook
i write off corporate expenses and pay
corporate taxes
i have different credit cards for myself
and my corporation
if we think of ourselves as a
corporation it gives us a healthy
distance on ourselves we're less
subjective we don't take blows as
personally we're more cold-blooded we
can price our wares more realistically
sometimes as joe blow himself i'm too
mild-mannered to go out and sell
but as joe blow incorporated i can pimp
the hell out of myself i'm not me
anymore i'm me incorporated
i'm a pro
a critter that keeps coming
why does resistance yield to our turning
pro
because resistance is a bully
resistance has no strength of its own
its power derives entirely from our fear
of it
a bully will back down before the
runtious twerp who stands his ground
the essence of professionalism is the
focus upon the work and its demands
while we are doing it to the exclusion
of all else the ancient spartans
schooled themselves to regard the enemy
any enemy as nameless and faceless in
other words they believed that if they
did their work
no force on earth could stand against
them
in the searchers john wayne and jeffrey
hunter pursue the war chief scar who has
kidnapped their young kinswoman played
by natalie wood
winter stops them but wayne's character
ethan edwards does not slacken his
resolve he'll return to the trail and
spring he declares and sooner or later
the fugitive's vigilance will slacken
ethan
seems he never learns there's such a
thing as a critter that might just keep
coming on
so we'll find him in the end i promise
you that
just as sure as the turning of the earth
the pro keeps coming on he beats
resistance at its own game by being even
more resolute and even more implacable
than it is
no mystery
there's no mystery to turning pro
it's a decision brought about by an act
of will
we make up our mind to view ourselves as
prose and we do it
simple as that
book three
beyond resistance
the higher realm
the first duty
is to sacrifice to the gods
and pray them to grant you the thoughts
words and deeds likely to render your
command most pleasing to the gods and to
bring yourself your friends and your
city the fullest measure of affection
and glory and advantage
xenophon
the cavalry commander
angels in the abstract
the next few chapters are going to be
about those invisible psychic forces
that support and sustain us in our
journey toward ourselves
i plan on using terms like muses
and angels
does that make you uncomfortable
if it does you have my permission to
think of angels in the abstract
consider these forces as being
impersonal as gravity
maybe they are
it's not hard to believe is it that a
force exists in every grain and seed to
make it grow
or that in every kitten or cult is an
instinct that impels it to run and play
and learn
just as resistance can be thought of as
personal i've said resistance loves such
and such are hates such and such
it can also be viewed as a force of
nature as impersonal as entropy or
molecular decay
similarly the call to growth can be
conceptualized as personal a diamond or
genius an angel or a muse or as
impersonal like the tides or the
transiting of venus either way works
as long as we're comfortable with it or
if extra dimensionality doesn't sit well
with you in any form think of it as
talent
programmed into our genes by evolution
the point for the thesis i'm seeking to
put forward
is that there are forces we can call our
allies
as resistance works to keep us from
becoming who we were born to be equal
and opposite powers are counter-poised
against it
these are our allies and angels
approaching the mystery
why have i stressed professionalism so
heavily in the preceding chapters
because the most important thing about
art
is to work
nothing else matters except sitting down
every day and trying
why is this so important because when we
sit down day after day and keep grinding
something mysterious starts to happen
a process is set into motion by which
inevitably and infallibly heaven comes
to our aid
unseen forces enlist in our cause
serendipity reinforces our purpose
this is the other secret that real
artists know and wannabe writers don't
when we sit down each day and do our
work
power concentrates around us
the muse takes note of our dedication
she approves
we have earned favor in her sight
when we sit down and work we become like
a magnetized rod that attracts iron
filings ideas come incites a crete
just as resistance has its seat in hell
so creation has its home in heaven
and it's not just a witness but an eager
and active ally
what i call professionalism someone else
might call the artist's code or the
warrior's way it's an attitude of
egolessness and service
the knights of the round table were
chased and self-effacing yet they dueled
dragons
we're facing dragons too
fire breathing griffons of the soul
whom we must out fight and outwit
to reach the treasure of our self in
potential and to release the maiden who
is god's plan and destiny for ourselves
and the answer to why we were put on
this planet
invoking the muse
the quote from xenophon that opens this
section
comes from a pamphlet called the cavalry
commander in which the celebrated
warrior and historian proffers
instruction to those young gentlemen who
aspire to be officers of the athenian
equestrian corps
he declares that the commander's first
duty before he mucks out a stable or
seeks funding from the defense review
board is to sacrifice to the gods and
invoke their aid
i do the same thing
the last thing i do before i sit down to
work
is say my prayer to the muse i say it
out loud in absolute earnest
only then do i get down to business
in my late 20s i rented a little house
in northern california i had gone there
to finish a novel or kill myself trying
by that time i had blown up a marriage
to a girl i loved with all my heart
screwed up two careers blah blah
etcetera all because though i had no
understanding of this at the time i
could not handle resistance
i had one novel nine tenths of the way
through and another at 99 hundredths
before i threw them in the trash
i couldn't finish them i didn't have the
guts
in yielding thus lead to resistance
i fell prey to every vice evil
distraction you name it mentioned here
for all leading nowhere and finally
washed up in this sleepy california town
with my chevy van my cat moe and my
antique smith corona
a guy named paul rink lived down the
street
look him up he's in henry miller's big
sir and the oranges of hieronymus bosch
paul was a writer
he lived in his camper moby dick
i started each day over coffee with paul
he turned me on to all kinds of authors
i had never heard of lectured me on
self-discipline dedication the evils of
the marketplace
but best of all he shared with me his
prayer
the invocation of the muse from homer's
odyssey the t e lawrence translation
paul typed it out for me on his even
more ancient than mine manuel remington
i still have it it's yellow and parched
as dust the merest puff would blow it to
powder
in my little house i had no tv i never
read a newspaper or went to a movie i
just worked
one afternoon i was banging away in a
little bedroom i had converted to an
office
when i heard my neighbor's radio playing
outside someone in a loud voice was
declaiming to preserve protect and
defend the constitution of the united
states
i came out
what's going on didn't you hear nixon's
out they got a new guy in there
i had missed watergate completely
i was determined to keep working
i had failed so many times and caused
myself and people i loved so much pain
thereby that i felt if i crapped out
this time
i would have to hang myself
didn't know what resistance was then no
one had schooled me in the concept
i felt it though big time i experienced
it as a compulsion to self-destruct
i could not finish what i started
the closer i got the more different ways
i'd find to screw it up
i worked for 26 months straight taking
only two out for a stint of migrant
labor in washington state and finally
one day
i got to the last page and typed out
the end
i never did find a buyer for the book or
the next one either
it was ten years before i got the first
check for something i had written and
ten more before a novel the legend of
bagger vance was actually published
but that moment when i first hit the
keys to spell out the end
was epical
i remember rolling the last page out and
adding it to the stack that was the
finished manuscript
nobody knew i was done nobody cared but
i knew
i felt like a dragon i'd been fighting
all my life had just dropped dead at my
feet and gasped out its last sulfuric
breath
rest in peace [ __ ]
next morning i went over to paul's for
coffee and told him i had finished
good for you he said without looking up
start the next one today
invoking the muse
part two
before i met paul i had never heard of
the muses
he enlightened me
the muses were nine sisters daughters of
zeus and nemasini which means memory
their names are clio arato
thalaya
terpsicary calliope polyhymnia uterpi
mel pamini and urania
their job is to inspire artists
each muse is responsible for a different
art
there's a neighborhood in new orleans
where the streets are named after the
muses i lived there once and had no idea
i thought they were just weird names
here's socrates in plato's fidres on the
noble effect of heaven-sent madness
the third type of possession and madness
is possession by the muses
when this seizes upon a gentle and
virgin soul it rouses it to inspired
expression in lyric and other sorts of
poetry and glorifies countless deeds of
the heroes of old for the instruction of
posterity
but if a man comes to the door of poetry
untouched by the madness of the muses
believing that technique alone will make
him a good poet
he and his sane compositions never reach
perfection but are utterly eclipsed by
the performances of the inspired madman
the greek way of apprehending the
mystery was to personify it
the ancients sensed powerful primordial
forces in the world
to make them approachable they gave them
human faces they called them zeus apollo
aphrodite
american indians felt the same mystery
but rendered it in animistic forms bear
teacher hawk messenger coyote trickster
our ancestors were keenly cognizant of
forces and energies whose seat was not
in this material sphere but in a loftier
more mysterious one what did they
believe about this higher reality first
they believed that death did not exist
there the gods are immortal
the gods though not unlike humans are
infinitely more
powerful to defy their will is futile to
act toward heaven with pride is to call
down calamity
time and space display an altered
existence in this higher dimension
the gods travel swift as thought
they can tell the future some of them
and though the playwright akkathon tells
us this alone is denied to god the power
to under the past
yet the immortals can play tricks with
time as we ourselves may sometimes in
dreams or visions
the universe the greeks believed was not
indifferent
the gods take an interest in human
affairs and intercede for good or ill in
our designs
the contemporary view is that all this
is charming but preposterous
is it
then answer this where did hamlet come
from
where did the parthenon come from
where did nude descending a staircase
come from
testament of a visionary
eternity is in love with the creations
of time
william blake
the visionary poet william blake
was so i understand one of those
half-man avatars who appear in flesh
from time to time savants capable of
ascending for brief periods to loftier
planes and returning to share the
wonders they have seen
shall we try to decipher the meaning of
the verse above
what blake means by eternity i think
is the sphere higher than this one
a plane of reality superior to the
material dimension in which we dwell
in eternity
there's no such thing as time
or blake's syntax wouldn't distinguish
it from eternity and probably no space
either
this plane may be inhabited by higher
creatures or it may be pure
consciousness or spirit
but whatever it is according to blake
it's capable of being in love
if beings inhabit this plane
i take blake to mean that they are
incorporeal
they don't have bodies
but they have a connection to the sphere
of time the one we live in
these gods or spirits participate in
this dimension they take an interest in
it
eternity is in love with the creations
of time means to me
that in some way these creatures of the
higher sphere or the sphere itself in
the abstract take joy in what we
time-bound beings can bring forth into
physical existence in our limited
material sphere
it may be pushing the envelope but if
these beings take joy in the creations
of time might they not also nudge us a
little to produce them
if that's true then the image of the
muse whispering inspiration in the
artist's ear is quite apt
the timeless
communicating to the time bound
by blake's model as i understand it it's
as though the fifth symphony existed
already in that higher sphere before
beethoven sat down and played da da da
da
the catch was this
the work existed only as potential
without a body so to speak it wasn't
music yet you couldn't play it you
couldn't hear it it needed someone
it needed a corporeal being a human an
artist or more precisely a genius in the
latin sense of soul or animating spirit
to bring it into being on this material
plane
so the muse whispered in beethoven's ear
maybe she hummed a few bars into a
million other years but no one else
heard her
only beethoven got it
he brought it forth
he made the fifth symphony a creation of
time which eternity
could be in love with
so that eternity whether we conceive of
it as god pure consciousness infinite
intelligence
omniscient spirit or if we choose to
think of it as beings gods spirits
avatars
when it or they hear somehow the sounds
of earthly music
it brings them joy
in other words blake agrees with the
greeks the gods do exist they do
penetrate our earthly sphere
which brings us back to the muse
the muse remember is the daughter of
zeus father of the gods and memory
pneumocene that's a pretty impressive
pedigree
i'll accept those credentials
i'll take xenophon at his word
before i sit down to work i'll take a
minute and show respect to this unseen
power who can make or break me
invoking the muse
part three
artists have invoked the muse since time
immemorial
there is great wisdom to this there is
magic to effacing our human arrogance
and humbly and treating help from a
source we cannot see hear touch or smell
here's the start of homer's odyssey the
t e lawrence translation
o divine poesy goddess daughter of zeus
sustain for me this song of the various
minded man who after he had plundered
the innermost citadel of hallowed troy
was made to stray grievously about the
coasts of men the sport of their customs
good and bad
while his heart through all the
seafaring ached with an agony to redeem
himself and bring his company safe home
vain hope for them the fools their own
witlessness cast them aside
to destroy for meat the oxen of the most
exalted sun wherefore the sun god
blotted out the day of their return
make this tale
live for us in all its many bearings
o muse
this passage will reward closer study
first
divine policy
when we invoke the muse we are calling
on a force not just from a different
plane of reality but from a holier plane
goddess daughter of zeus
not only are we invoking divine
intercession
but intercession on the highest level
just one remove from the top
sustain for me
homer doesn't ask for brilliance or
success
he just wants to keep this thing going
this song
that about covers it from the brothers
karamazov to your new venture in the
plumbing supply business
i love the summation of odysseus trials
that comprises the body of the
invocation it's joseph campbell's heroes
journey in a nutshell as concise a
synopsis of the story of every man as it
gets
there's the initial crime which we all
inevitably commit
which ejects the hero from his homebound
complacency and propels him upon his
wanderings the yearning for redemption
the untiring campaign to get home
meaning back to god's grace back to
himself
i admire particularly the warning
against the second crime to destroy for
meat the oxen of the most exalted son
that's the felony that calls down soul
destruction the employment of the sacred
for profane means
prostitution
selling out
lastly
the artist's wish for his work make this
tale
live for us in all its many bearings o
muse
that's what we want isn't it
more than make it great
make it live
and not from one angle only but in all
its many bearings
okay
we've said our prayer
we're ready to work
now what
the magic
of making a start
concerning all acts of initiative and
creation
there is one elementary truth the
ignorance of which kills countless ideas
and splendid plans
that the moment one definitely commits
oneself
then providence moves too
all sorts of things occur to help one
that would not otherwise have occurred
a whole stream of events issues from the
decision raising in one's favor all
manner of unforeseen incidents and
meetings and material assistance which
no man would have dreamed would come his
way
i have learned a deep respect for one of
good his couplets
whatever you can do or dream you can
begin it
boldness has genius
magic and power in it begin it now
w h murray
the scottish himalayan expedition
did you ever see wings of desire whim
wanders his film about angels among us
city of angels with meg ryan and nicolas
cage was the american version
i believe it i believe there are angels
they're here but we can't see them
angels work for god it's their job to
help us wake us up bump us along
angels are agents of evolution
the kabbalah describes angels as bundles
of light meaning intelligence
consciousness
kabbalists believe that above every
blade of grass is an angel crying
grow
grow
i'll go further i believe that above the
entire human race is one super angel
crying evolve
evolve
angels are like muses they know stuff we
don't they want to help us
they're on the other side of a pane of
glass shouting to get our attention but
we can't hear them
we're too distracted by our own nonsense
ah but when we begin
when we make a start
when we conceive an enterprise and
commit to it in the face of our fears
something wonderful happens
a crack appears in the membrane like the
first craze when a chick pecks at the
inside of its shell
angel midwives congregate around us they
assist as we give birth to ourselves to
that person we were born to be to the
one whose destiny was encoded in our
soul our diamond our genius
when we make a beginning
we get out of our own way and allow the
angels to come in and do their job
they can speak to us now and it makes
them happy it makes god happy eternity
as blake might have told us
has opened a portal into time
and we're it
the magic of keeping going
when i finish a day's work
i head up into the hills for a hike
i take a pocket tape recorder because i
know that as my surface mind empties
with the walk another part of me will
chime in and start talking
the word lear on page 342 it should be
ogle
you repeated yourself in chapter 21 the
last sentence is just like that one in
the middle of chapter seven
that's the kind of stuff that comes it
comes to all of us every day every
minute
these paragraphs i'm writing now were
dictated to me yesterday they replace a
prior weaker opening to this chapter
i'm unspooling the new improved version
now right off the recorder
this process of self-revision and
self-correction is so common we don't
even notice but it's a miracle
and its implications are staggering
who's doing this revising anyway
what force is yanking in our sleeves
what does it tell us about the
architecture of our psyches that without
our exerting effort or even thinking
about it
some voice in our head
pipes up to counsel us
and counsel us wisely
on how to do our work and live our lives
whose voice is it
what software is grinding away scanning
gigabytes while we our mainstream selves
are otherwise occupied
are these angels
are they muses
is this the unconscious
the self
whatever it is it's smarter than we are
a lot smarter it doesn't need us to tell
it what to do it goes to work all by
itself
it seems to want to work it seems to
enjoy it
what exactly is it doing
it's organizing
the principle of organization is built
into nature
chaos itself is self-organizing out of
primordial disorder stars find their
orbits
rivers make their way to the sea
when we like god set out to create a
universe a book an opera a new business
venture
the same principle kicks in
our screenplay resolves itself into a
three-act structure
our symphony takes shape into movements
our plumbing supply venture discovers
its optimum chain of command
how do we experience this
by having ideas
insights pop into our heads while we're
shaving or taking a shower or even
amazingly while we're actually working
the elves behind this are smart if we
forget something they remind us
if we veer off course they trim the tabs
and steer us back
what can we conclude from this
clearly some intelligence is at work
independent of our conscious mind and
yet in alliance with it
processing our material for us and
alongside us
this is why artists are modest
they know they're not doing the work
they're just taking dictation it's also
why non-creative people hate creative
people
because they're jealous
they sense that artists and writers are
tapped into some grid of energy and
inspiration that they themselves cannot
connect with
of course this is nonsense we're all
creative we all have the same psyche the
same everyday miracles are happening in
all our heads day by day minute by
minute
largo
in my 20s
i drove tractor trailers for a company
called burton lines in durham north
carolina
i wasn't very good at it
my self-destruction demons had me only
blind luck kept me from killing myself
and any other poor suckers who happened
to be on the highway at the same time
it was a tough period i was broke
estranged from my wife and my family
one night i had this dream
i was part of the crew of an aircraft
carrier
only the ship was stuck on dry land
it was still launching its jets and
doing its thing but it was marooned half
a mile from the ocean
the sailors all knew how screwed up the
situation was they felt it as a keen and
constant distress the only bright spot
was there was a marine gunnery sergeant
on board nicknamed largo
in the dream it seemed like the coolest
name anyone could possibly have largo i
loved it
largo was one of those hardcore senior
non-coms like the burt lancaster
character warden in from here to
eternity the one guy in the ship who
knows exactly what's going on the tough
old sarge who makes all the decisions
and actually runs the show
but where was largo
i was standing miserably by the rail
when the captain came over and started
talking to me even he was lost
it was his ship but he didn't know how
to get it off dry land
i was nervous finding myself in
conversation with the brass and couldn't
think of a thing to say
the skipper didn't seem to notice he
just turned to me casually and said what
the hell are we going to do largo
i woke up
electrified
i was largo
i was the salty old gunny the power to
take charge was in my hands all i had to
do was believe it
where did this dream come from
plainly its intent was benevolent what
was its source
and what does it say about the workings
of the universe that such things happen
at all
again we've all had dreams like that
again they're common as dirt so is the
sunrise
that doesn't make it any less a miracle
before i got to north carolina i worked
in the oil fields around burus louisiana
i lived in a bunk house with a bunch of
other transient geeks
one guy had picked up a paperback about
meditation in a bookstore in new orleans
he was teaching me how to do it
i used to go out to this doc after work
and see if i could get into it one night
this came
i was sitting cross-legged when an eagle
came and landed on my shoulders
the eagle merged with me and took off
flying so that my head became its head
and my arms its wings
it felt completely authentic
i could feel the air under my wings as
solid as water feels when you row in it
with an oar
it was substantial you could push off
against it
so this was how birds flew i realized
that it was impossible for a bird to
fall out of the sky all it would have to
do is extend its wings
the solid air would hold it up with the
same power we feel when we stick our
hand out the window of a moving car
i was pretty impressed with this movie
that was playing in my head but i still
had no idea what it meant
i asked the eagle hey what am i supposed
to be learning from this
a voice answered silently
you're supposed to learn that things
that you think are nothing as weightless
as air are actually powerful substantial
forces as real and as solid as earth
i understood
the eagle was telling me that dreams
visions meditations such as this very
one things that i had till now disdained
as fantasy and illusion were as real and
as solid as anything in my waking life
i believe the eagle i got the message
how could i not
i had felt the solidness of the air i
knew he was telling the truth
which brings us back to the question
where did the eagle come from
why did he show up at just the right
time to tell me just what i needed to
hear
clearly some unseen intelligence had
created him giving him form as an eagle
so that i would understand what had
wanted to communicate
this intelligence was babying me along
keeping it simple
making its point in terms so clear and
elementary
that even someone as numb and asleep as
i was could understand
life and death
remember the movie billy jack
starring tom lachlan
the film and its sequels have long since
decamped to cable but tom lachlan is
still very much around
in addition to his movie work he's a
lecturer and author and a jungian school
psychologist whose specialty is working
with people who have been diagnosed with
cancer
tom lachlan teaches and leads workshops
here's a paraphrase of something i heard
him say
the moment a person learns he's got
terminal cancer
a profound shift takes place in his
psyche at one stroke in the doctor's
office he becomes aware of what really
matters to him
things that 60 seconds earlier had
seemed all important suddenly appear
meaningless
while people and concerns that he had
till then dismissed at once take on
supreme importance
maybe he realizes working this weekend
on that big deal at the office isn't all
that vital
maybe it's more important to fly
cross-country for his grandson's
graduation
maybe it isn't so crucial that he have
the last word in the fight with his wife
maybe instead he should tell her how
much she means to him and how deeply he
has always loved her
other thoughts occurred to the patient
diagnosed as terminal what about that
gift he had for music
what became of the passion he once felt
to work with the sick and the homeless
why do these unlived lives return now
with such power and poignancy
faced with our imminent extinction
tom lachlan believes all assumptions are
called into question
what does our life mean have we lived it
right are there vital acts we've left
unperformed crucial words unspoken is it
too late
the ego young tells us is that part of
the psyche that we think of as i
our conscious intelligence
our everyday brain that thinks plans and
runs the show of our day-to-day life
the self as young defined it is a
greater entity which includes the ego
but also incorporates the personal and
collective
unconscious dreams and intuitions come
from the self
the archetypes of the unconscious dwell
there it is jung believed the sphere of
the soul
what happens in that instant when we
learn we may soon die
tom laughlin contends is that the seat
of our consciousness shifts
it moves from the ego to the self
the world is entirely new viewed from
the self
at once we discern what's really
important superficial concerns fall away
replaced by a deeper more profoundly
grounded perspective
this is how tom lachlan's foundation
battles cancer he counsels his clients
not just to make that shift mentally
but to live it out in their lives
he supports the housewife in resuming
her career in social work urges the
businessman to return to the violin
assists the vietnam vet to write his
novel
miraculously cancers go into remission
people recover
is it possible tom lachlan asks that the
disease itself evolved as a consequence
of actions taken or not taken in our
lives
could our unlived lives have exacted
their vengeance upon us in the form of
cancer
and if they did
can we cure ourselves now
by living these lives out
the ego and the self
here's what i think i think angels make
their home in the self
while resistance
has its seat in the ego
the fight is between the two
the self wishes to create to evolve
the ego likes things just the way they
are
what is the ego anyway since this is my
book i'll define it my way the ego is
that part of the psyche that believes in
material existence
the ego's job is to take care of
business in the real world it's an
important job we couldn't last a day
without it
but there are worlds other than the real
world and this is where the ego runs
into trouble
here's what the ego believes
1.
death is real
the ego believes that our existence is
defined by our physical flesh when the
body dies we die there is no life beyond
life
2.
time and space are real
the ego is analog it believes that to
get from a to z we have to pass through
b c and d
to get from breakfast to supper we have
to live the whole day three every
individual is different and separate
from every other
the ego believes that i am distinct from
you the twain cannot meet i can hurt you
and it won't hurt me
four the predominant impulse of life is
self-preservation
because our existence is physical and
thus vulnerable to innumerable evils
we live and act out of fear in all we do
it is wise the ego believes to have
children to carry on our line when we
die to achieve great things that will
live after us and to buckle our seat
belts
five
there is no god
no sphere exists
except the physical and no rules apply
except those of the material world
these are the principles the ego lives
by they are sound solid principles
here's what the self believes
one
death is an illusion
the soul endures and evolves through
infinite manifestations
two
time and space are illusions
time and space operate only in the
physical sphere and even here don't
apply to dreams visions transports in
other dimensions we move swift as
thought and inhabit multiple planes
simultaneously
three all beings are one if i hurt you
i hurt myself
four
the supreme emotion is love
union and mutual assistance are the
imperatives of life
we are all in this together
five
god is all there is
everything that is
is god in one form or another
god the divine ground is that in which
we live and move and have our being
infinite planes of reality exist all
created by sustained by and infused by
the spirit of god
experiencing the self
have you ever wondered
why the slang terms for intoxication are
so demolition oriented stoned smashed
hammered
it's because they're talking about the
ego it's the ego that gets blasted waxed
plastered we demolish the ego
to get to the self
the margins of the self touch upon the
divine ground meaning the mystery the
void the source of infinite wisdom and
consciousness
dreams come from the self
ideas come from the self
when we meditate we access the self when
we fast when we pray
when we go on a vision quest it's the
self we're seeking
when the dervish whirls when the yogi
chants when the sadhu mutilates his
flesh when penitents crawl a hundred
miles on their knees when native
americans pierce themselves in the sun
dance when suburban kids take ecstasy
and dance all night at a rave they're
seeking the self
when we deliberately alter our
consciousness in any way we're trying to
find the self when the alcoholic
collapses in the gutter that voice that
tells him i'll save you
comes from the self
the self is our deepest being
the self is united to god the self is
incapable of falsehood
the self like the divine ground that
permeates it is ever growing and ever
evolving
the self speaks for the future that's
why the ego hates it
the ego hates the self because when we
seat our consciousness in the self we
put the ego out of business
the ego doesn't want us to evolve the
ego runs the show right now it likes
things just the way they are
the instinct that pulls us toward art
is the impulse to evolve to learn to
heighten and elevate our consciousness
the ego hates this
because the more awake we become
the less we need the ego
the ego hates it when the awakening
writer sits down at the typewriter the
ego hates it when the aspiring painter
steps up before the easel
the ego hates it because it knows that
these souls are awakening to a call and
that that call comes from a plane nobler
than the material one and from a source
deeper and more powerful than the
physical
the ego hates the prophet and the
visionary because they propel the race
upward
the ego hated socrates and jesus luther
and galileo lincoln and jfk and martin
luther king
the ego hates artists because they are
the pathfinders and bearers of the
future because each one dares in james
joyce's phrase to forge in the smithy of
my soul the uncreated conscience of my
race
such evolution is life-threatening to
the ego
it reacts accordingly it summons its
cunning marshals its troops the ego
produces
resistance
and attacks the awakening artist
fear
resistance feeds on fear
we experience resistance as fear but
fear of what
fear of the consequences of following
our heart
fear of bankruptcy fear of poverty fear
of insolvency fear of groveling when we
try to make it on our own and of
groveling when we give up and come
crawling back to where we started
fear of being selfish
of being rotten wives or disloyal
husbands
fear of failing to support our families
of sacrificing their dreams for ours
fear of betraying our race our hood our
homies fear of failure fear of being
ridiculous
fear of throwing away the education the
training the preparation that those we
love have sacrificed so much for that we
ourselves have worked our butts off for
fear of launching into the void of
hurtling too far out there fear of
passing some point of no return beyond
which we cannot recant cannot reverse
cannot rescind but must live with this
cocked up choice for the rest of our
lives
fear of madness
fear of insanity
fear of death
these are serious fears
but they're not the real fear not the
master fear the mother of all fears
that's so close to us that even when we
verbalize it we don't believe it
fear
that we will succeed
that we can access the powers we
secretly know we possess that we can
become the person we sense in our hearts
we truly are
this is the most terrifying prospect a
human being can face because it ejects
him at one go he imagines from all the
tribal inclusions his psyche is wired
for and has been for 50 million years
we fear discovering that we are more
than we think we are
more than our parents children teachers
think we are we fear that we actually
possess the talent that our still small
voice tells us
that we actually have the guts the
perseverance the capacity
we fear that we truly can steer our ship
plant our flag reach our promised land
we fear this because if it's true
then we become estranged from all we
know
we pass through a membrane
we become monsters
and monstrous
we know that if we embrace our ideals we
must prove worthy of them and that
scares the hell out of us
what will become of us
we will lose our friends and family who
will no longer recognize us we will wind
up alone in the cold void of starry
space with nothing and no one to hold on
to
of course this is exactly what happens
but here's the trick
we wind up in space
but not alone
instead we are tapped into an
unquenchable undepletable inexhaustible
source of wisdom
consciousness
companionship
yeah we lose friends but we find friends
too in places we never thought to look
and they're better friends truer friends
and we're better endured to them
do you believe me
the authentic self
do you have kids
then you know that not one of them
popped out as tabula rasa a blank slate
each came into this world with a
distinct and unique personality and
identity so set that you can fling
stardust and great balls of fire at it
and not morph it by one micro dot
each kid was who he was even identical
twins constituted of the exact same
genetic material were radically
different from day one and always would
be
personally
i'm with wordsworth
our birth is but a sleep and a
forgetting
the soul that rises with us our life's
star hath had elsewhere it's setting and
cometh from afar not in entire
forgetfulness and not in utter nakedness
but trailing clouds of glory do we come
from god
who is our home
in other words none of us are born as
passive generic blobs waiting for the
world to stamp its imprint on us
instead we show up possessing already a
highly refined and individuated soul
another way of thinking of it is this
we're not born with unlimited choices we
can't be anything we want to be
we come into this world with a specific
personal destiny we have a job to do a
calling to an act a self to become
we are who we are from the cradle and
we're stuck with it
our job in this lifetime is not to shape
ourselves into some ideal we imagine we
ought to be but to find out who we
already are and become it
if we were born to paint it's our job to
become a painter
if we were born to raise and nurture
children it's our job to become a mother
if we were born to overthrow the order
of ignorance and injustice of the world
it's our job to realize it and get down
to business
territory versus hierarchy
in the animal kingdom
individuals defined themselves in one of
two ways
by their rank within a hierarchy a hen
in a pecking order a wolf in a pack
or by their connection to a territory a
home base a hunting ground a turf
this is how individuals humans as well
as animals achieve psychological
security they know where they stand the
world makes sense
of the two orientations the hierarchical
seems to be the default setting it's the
one that kicks in automatically when
we're kids
we run naturally in packs and cliques
without thinking about it we know who's
the top dog and who's the underdog
and we know our own place we define
ourselves instinctively it seems by our
position within the schoolyard the gang
the club
it's only later in life usually after a
stern education in the university of
hard knox that we begin to explore the
territorial alternative
for some of us this saves our lives
the hierarchical orientation
most of us define ourselves
hierarchically and don't even know it
it's hard not to school advertising the
entire materialist culture drills us
from birth to define ourselves by others
opinions drink this beer get this job
look this way and everyone will love you
what is a hierarchy anyway
hollywood is a hierarchy so are
washington wall street and the daughters
of the american revolution
high school is the ultimate hierarchy
and it works
in a pond that small the hierarchical
orientation succeeds the cheerleader
knows where she fits as does the dweeb
in the chess club each has found a niche
the system works
there's a problem with the hierarchical
orientation though when the numbers get
too big
the thing breaks down
a pecking order can hold only so many
chickens
in massapequa high you can find your
place move to manhattan and the trick no
longer works
new york city is too big to function as
a hierarchy so as ibm so is michigan
state
the individual in multitudes this vast
feels overwhelmed anonymous
he is submerged in the mass he's lost
we humans seem to have been wired by our
evolutionary past to function most
comfortably in a tribe of twenty to say
eight hundred
we can push it maybe to a few thousand
even to five figures but at some point
it maxes out
our brains can't file that many faces we
thrash around flashing our badges of
status hey how do you like my lincoln
navigator
and wondering why nobody gives a [ __ ]
we have entered mass society
the hierarchy is too big
it doesn't work anymore
the artist
and the hierarchy
for the artist to define himself
hierarchically is
fatal let's examine why first let's look
at what happens in a hierarchical
orientation
an individual who defines himself by his
place in a pecking order will one
compete against all others in the order
seeking to elevate his station by
advancing against those above him while
defending his place against those
beneath
two
evaluate his happiness success
achievement by his rank within the
hierarchy feeling most satisfied when
he's high and most miserable when he's
low
three act toward others based upon their
rank in the hierarchy to the exclusion
of all other factors
four evaluate his every move solely by
the effect it produces on others he will
act for others dress for others speak
for others
think for others
but the artist cannot look to others to
validate his efforts or his calling
if you don't believe me ask van gogh who
produced masterpiece after masterpiece
and never found a buyer in his whole
life
the artist must operate territorially he
must do his work for its own sake
to labor in the arts for any reason
other than love is prostitution
recall the fate of odysseus's men who
slew the cattle of the sun
their own witlessness cast them away the
fools
to destroy for meat the oxen of the most
exalted sun wherefore the sun god
blotted out the day of their return
in the hierarchy the artist faces
outward
meeting someone new he asks himself what
can this person do for me how can this
person advance my standing
in the hierarchy
the artist looks up and looks down
the one place he can't look
is that place he must
within
the definition
of a hack
i learned this from robert mckee
a hack he says
is a writer who second guesses his
audience
when the hack sits down to work he
doesn't ask himself what's in his own
heart he asks what the market is looking
for
the hack condescends to his audience he
thinks he's superior to them the truth
is he's scared to death of them or more
accurately scared of being authentic in
front of them scared of writing what he
really feels or believes what he himself
thinks is interesting he's afraid it
won't sell
so he tries to anticipate what the
market a telling word
wants then gives it to them
in other words the hack writes
hierarchically he writes what he
imagines will play well in the eyes of
others
he does not ask himself what do i myself
want to write what do i think is
important instead he asks what's hot
what can i make a deal for
the hack is like the politician who
consults the polls before he takes a
position he's a demagogue he panders
it can pay off being a hack
given the depraved state of american
culture a slick dude can make millions
being a hack but even if you succeed you
lose
because you've sold out your muse and
your muse as you
the best part of yourself where your
finest and only true work comes from
i was starving as a screenwriter when
the idea for the legend of beggar vance
came to me
it came as a book not a movie
i met with my agent to give him the bad
news we both knew that first novels take
forever and sell for nothing worse a
novel about golf even if we could find a
publisher is a straight shot to the
remainder bin
but the muse had me
i had to do it
to my amazement the book succeeded
critically and commercially better than
anything i'd ever done
and others since have been lucky too
why
my best guess is this i trusted what i
wanted not what i thought would work
i did what i myself thought was
interesting and left its reception to
the gods
the artist can't do his work
hierarchically he has to work
territorially
the territorial orientation
there's a three-legged coyote who lives
up the hill from me all the garbage cans
in the neighborhood belong to him it's
his territory
every now and then some four-legged
intruder tries to take over they can't
do it on his home turf even a peg-leg
critter is invincible
we humans have territories too
ours are psychological
stevie wonder's territory is the piano
arnold schwarzeneggers is the gym
when bill gates pulls into the parking
lot at microsoft he's on his territory
when i sit down to write i'm on mine
what are the qualities of a territory
one a territory provides sustenance
runners know what a territory is so do
rock climbers and kayakers and yogis
artists and entrepreneurs know what a
territory is the swimmer who towels off
after finishing her laps feels a hell of
a lot better than the tired cranky
person who dove into the pool 30 minutes
earlier
two a territory sustains us without any
external input
a territory is a closed feedback loop
our role is to put in effort and love
the territory absorbs this
and gives it back to us in the form of
well-being
when experts tell us that exercise or
any other effort requiring activity
banishes depression this is what they
mean
three
a territory can only be claimed
alone you can team with a partner you
can work out with a friend but you only
need yourself to soak up your
territory's juice
four
a territory can only be claimed by work
when arnold schwarzenegger hits the gym
he's on his own turf
but what made it his own are the hours
and years of sweat he put in to claim it
the territory doesn't give it gives back
five
a territory returns exactly what you put
in
territories are fair every erg of energy
you put in goes infallibly into your
account
a territory never devalues
a territory never crashes
what you deposited you get back dollar
for dollar
what's your territory
the artist
and the territory
the act of creation is by definition
territorial
as the mother-to-be bears her child
within her so the artist or innovator
contains her new life
no one can help her give it birth but
neither does she need any help
the mother and the artist are watched
over by heaven
nature's wisdom knows when it's time for
the life within to switch from gills to
lungs it knows down to the nanosecond
when the first tiny fingernails may
appear
when the artist acts hierarchically she
short-circuits the muse she insults her
and pisses her off
the artist and the mother are vehicles
not originators they don't create the
new life they only bear it
this is why birth is such a humbling
experience the new mom weeps in awe at
the little miracle in her arms she knows
it came out of her but not from her
through her but not of her
when the artist works territorially she
reveres heaven she aligns herself with
the mysterious forces that power the
universe and that seek through her to
bring forth new life
by doing her work for its own sake
she sets herself at the service of these
forces
remember as artists we don't know diddly
we're winging it every day
for us to try to second-guess our muse
the way a hack second-guesses his
audience is condescension to heaven it's
blasphemy and sacrilege
instead let's ask ourselves like that
new mother what do i feel growing inside
me let me bring that forth if i can for
its own sake and not for what it can do
for me or how it can advance my standing
the difference between territory
and hierarchy
how can we tell
if our orientation is territorial or
hierarchical
one way is to ask ourselves if i were
feeling really anxious what would i do
if we would pick up the phone and call
six friends one after the other with the
aim of hearing their voices and
reassuring ourselves that they still
love us or operating hierarchically
we're seeking the good opinion of others
what would arnold schwarzenegger do on a
freaky day he wouldn't phone his buddies
he'd head for the gym
he wouldn't care if the place was empty
if he didn't say a word to a soul he
knows that working out all by itself is
enough to bring him back to his center
his orientation is territorial
here's another test of any activity you
do ask yourself if i were the last
person on earth
would i still do it
if you're all alone on the planet a
hierarchical orientation makes no sense
there's no one to impress so if you'd
still pursue that activity
congratulations you're doing it
territorially
if arnold schwarzenegger were the last
man on earth he'd still go to the gym
stevie wonder would still pound the
piano
the sustenance they get comes from the
act itself not from the impression it
makes on others
i have a friend who's nuts for clothes
if she were the last woman on earth she
would shoot straight to javon she or
saller smash her way in and start
pillaging
in her case it wouldn't be to impress
others she just loves clothes that's her
territory
now
what about ourselves as artists
how do we do our work hierarchically or
territorially
if we were freaked out would we go there
first
if we were the last person on earth
would we still show up at the studio the
rehearsal hall the laboratory
the supreme virtue
someone once asked the spartan king
leonidas to identify the supreme warrior
virtue from which all others flowed he
replied contempt for death
for us as artists read
failure
contempt for failure is our cardinal
virtue by confining our attention
territorially to our own thoughts and
actions in other words to the work and
its demands
we cut the earth from beneath the blue
painted shield banging spear brandishing
foe
the fruits of our labor
when krishna instructed arjuna that we
have a right to our labor but not to the
fruits of our labor he was counseling
the warrior to act territorially not
hierarchically
we must do our work for its own sake not
for fortune or attention or applause
then there's the third way proffered by
the lord of discipline which is beyond
both hierarchy and territory that is to
do the work and give it to him
do it as an offering to god
give the act to me purged of hope and
ego fix your attention on the soul act
and do for me
the work comes from heaven anyway why
not give it back
to labor in this way the bhagavad-gita
tells us is a form of meditation and a
supreme species of spiritual devotion
it also i believe conforms most closely
to higher reality
in fact we are servants of the mystery
we were put here on earth to act as
agents of the infinite to bring into
existence that which is not yet but
which will be through us
every breath we take
every heartbeat
every evolution of every cell comes from
god and is sustained by god every second
just as every creation invention every
bar of music or line of verse every
thought vision fantasy every dumb ass
flop and stroke of genius comes from
that infinite intelligence that created
us and the universe in all its
dimensions out of the void
the field of infinite potential primal
chaos
the muse
to acknowledge that reality to a face
all ego
to let the work come through us and give
it back freely to its source that in my
opinion is as true to reality as it gets
portrait of the artist
in the end
we arrive at a kind of model of the
artist's world and that model is that
there exist other higher planes of
reality about which we can prove nothing
but from which arise our lives our work
and our art
these spheres are trying to communicate
with ours
when blake said eternity is in love with
the creations of time he was referring
to those planes of pure potential which
are timeless placeless spaceless but
which long to bring their visions into
being here in this time-bound
space-defined world
the artist is the servant of that
intention those angels that muse
the enemy of the artist is the small
time ego which begets resistance which
is the dragon that guards the gold
that's why an artist must be a warrior
and like all warriors artists over time
acquire modesty and humility
they may some of them
conduct themselves flamboyantly in
public but alone with the work
they are chaste and humble
they know they are not the source of the
creations they bring into being
they only facilitate they carry they are
the willing and skilled instruments of
the gods and goddesses they serve
the artist's life
are you a born writer
were you put on earth to be a painter a
scientist an apostle of peace
in the end the question can only be
answered by action
do it or don't do it
it may help to think of it this way if
you are meant to cure cancer or write a
symphony or crack cold fusion and you
don't do it you not only hurt yourself
even destroy yourself you hurt your
children
you hurt me you hurt the planet
you shame the angels who watch over you
and you spite the almighty who created
you and only you with your unique gifts
for the sole purpose of nudging the
human race one millimeter farther along
its path back to god
creative work is not a selfish act or a
bid for attention on the part of the
actor it's a gift to the world and every
being in it
don't cheat us of your contribution
give us what you've got
the end
you've been listening to
the war of art
winning the inner creative battle
by steven pressfield
narrated by george waddell
if you've enjoyed this book and this
performance recorded books recommends
the novel gates of fire
also by steven pressfield and narrated
by george gwadel
and
telling lies for fun and profit a manual
for fiction writers
both written and narrated by lawrence
block
you'll find a wide selection of titles
in the recorded books catalog
including bestsellers mysteries classics
histories and more
so to order another recorded book or for
a copy of our latest listing please call
us using the toll-free number found on
the back of the book
you can order by phone with any major
credit card or by writing to us
or by faxing us
don't forget to ask about easy 30-day
rentals by mail
on our website you can browse the
catalog hear about the latest releases
place orders or tune into narrator
profiles and author interviews
so visit us there at
www.recordedbooks.com
and thank you
for being a recorded books reader